हेलो
एवरीवन एंड वेरी गुड इवनिंग टू
ऑल तो सबसे पहले मुझे यह बता दीजिए कि आई
एम
ऑडिबल सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है
प्लीज बता
दीजिए ओके प्रणय थैंक
यू तो थोड़ा सा दो मिनट के लिए वेट करते
हैं कि ताकि जो बाकी स्टूडेंट्स है वह भी
जवाइन कर ले क्लास को फिर हम अपने आज एक
नया टॉपिक है जिसको हम स्टार्ट करेंगे
सबको पता चल गया होगा कि आप ने जब
थंबनेल्स देखा होगा तो शायद सबको पता चल
गया होगा कि टॉपिक हमारा क्या है तो तब तक
आप मुझे यह बताइए कि
सबने जो सीटीएफ थ था ब्रुकलिन 99 सबने
सॉल्व किया जो मैंने एज ए टास्क आपको
प्रोवाइड किया था सबने सॉल्व
किया
एवरीवन बताइए जबसे अभी मैं चैट देख रहा
आपकी प्लीज
बताइए ओके देर ओनली टू स्टूडेंट्स बाकी
लोग बाकी ने क्या
किया बहुत इजी सीटीएफ था अगर आपने ध्यान
से दो सीटीएफ परफॉर्म किए होंगे जो हमारे
वाले जो मैंने आपको सिखाए थे काफी डिटेल्स
में टेक्निक के साथ तो अब ये थर्ड सीटीएफ
ऑटोमेटिक कर लेते क्योंकि ये जो सीटीएफ य
दो टेक्निक के द्वारा सॉल्व किया जा सकता
था एक टेक्निक आपको सॉल्व करने के लिए
मैंने एज ए टास्क प्रोवाइड की थी दूसरी जो
टेक्निक्स है उसको अभी हम परफॉर्म करेंगे
तो तब तक के लिए आप मुझे यह बता
दीजिए तो देव शरण बधाई हो आपको
कांग्रेचुलेशन कि आपको 5 के की बाउंट मिली
है तो थैंक यू तो बधाई हो आपको
को और हम उम्मीद करेंगे कि आप और भी
ज्यादा बाउंटीज फाइंड आउट करें आप मिले
आपको ज्यादा से
ज्यादा स दे आर ओनली टू स्टूडेंट
जिन्होंने परफॉर्म किया
है ओपन वीपीएन में क्या प्रॉब्लम आ रहा है
विष्णु विष्णु ओपन वीपीएन में प्रॉब्लम
नहीं आएगा प्रॉब्लम यह है कि ओपन वीपीएन
के अगर आप किसी पर्टिकुलर कंट्री की फाइल
को डाउनलोड कर रहे हो उसके बाद उसको रन कर
रहे हो तो एक काम कीजिए फिर से अकाउंट को
लॉग इन लॉग आउट कीजिए फाइल को री जनरेट
कीजिए और सर्वर चेंज कर लीजिए देन उसके
बाद ट्राई कीजिए और सबसे पहले आप अपनी
मशीन को अपडेट कर लीजिए सुडो अपडेट करके
एटी अपडेट सो दैट आपको आपकी फाइल अच्छे से
रन कर पाए ओके
तो दे आर ओनली टू स्टूडेंट जिन्होंने
हमारे दिए हुए टास्क को कंप्लीट किया एक
स्टूडेंट था जिन्होंने मेरे को पर्सनली
मैसेज किया हुआ है लिंकडन पर तो अच्छी बात
है तो उन्होंने सॉल्व किया है तो जो
फर्स्ट वे था आपको अभी भी एज ए टास्क
प्रोवाइड किया है तो मैं चाहूंगा कि आप
लोग खुद से उसको सॉल्व कीजिए और जो सेकंड
तरीका है जो एक नया तरीका है उसको हम
डिस्कस करेंगे आज सीखेंगे ओके तो उसके बाद
हम नेक्स्ट जैसे कि आज टेगो ग्राफी टॉपिक
रहेगा हमारा जसे जो आज हरा टॉपिक है वह
स्टैग एनालिसिस है तो हम स्टैग एनालिसिस
की हेल्प से सीटीएफ का परफॉर्म करेंगे और
डोंट वरी कि आज की क्लास में सीटीएफ
कंप्लीट नहीं होगा बेसिकली आज का सीटीएफ
कंप्लीट हो जाएगा नेक्स्ट जो सीटीएफ होगा
उसमें भी स्टैक एनालिसिस का पार्ट रहेगा
ओके हां आप किसी को भी कनेक्ट कर सकते हो
तो स्टार्ट करें तब तक बताइए दे ओनली 33
स्टूडेंट्स
तो आइए सबसे पहले हम टॉपिक की शुरुआत करते
हैं कि टॉपिक हमारा क्या है
और उसके बारे में थोड़ा इंट्रोडक्शन
कंप्लीट करते हैं कि स्टैगो ग्राफी होता
क्या है स्टैग एनालिसिस होता क्या है देन
उसके बाद हम प्रैक्टिकली परफॉर्म करेंगे
जो हमेशा हमारी अप्रोच रहती है ओके
स्टार्ट करें क्लास
को आर यू रेडी
गाइस देखिए मैं चाहता हूं कि आप क्लास में
ज्यादा से ज्यादा पार्टिसिपेट करें सीटीएफ
को ज्यादा से ज्यादा खुद की रुचि से सॉल्व
करें वक थ्रो की हेल्प ना ले किसी की
गाइडेंस या
जो भी टूल्स होता है उसको एक्सप्लेन करने
के लिए मैं आपको या तो चीट चीट आपके सामने
दिखा दे शो कर देता हूं या मैं आपको क्या
करता हूं बता देता हूं या मैक्सिमम जो
अप्रोच है मैं आपको काफी डिटेल तरीके से
बता देता जस्ट आपको क्या करना है फॉलो
करना है और खुद की मेथड बनानी है बस इतना
ही करना है इससे ज्यादा मैं आपको नहीं
बोलता क्योंकि आप एक बिगनर है और बिगनर एज
ए बिगनर आप इतना भी कर लोगे तो आपके लिए
काफी है धीरे-धीरे हम लेवल अप करेंगे अपने
आप को चिंता करने की क्योंकि अभी आपको मैं
सच बताऊं तो जो पार्ट चल रहा है आपका ये
नक् हैकिंग चल रहा है अगर आप ये नक्
हैकिंग काफी लैब तक चलने वाला है एटलीस्ट
नाइन सीटीएफ या एट सीटीएफ रहेंगे जो
जिसको हम बोलते हैं द आर्ट ऑफ हाइडिंट
एंड स्टैग एनालिसिस जो आज मैं आपको
सिखाऊंगा कैसे परफॉर्म स्टैगो ग्राफी कैसे
करते हैं यह हमारे अभी मैं इसको बताऊंगा
नहीं आपको लेकिन स्टैग एनालिसिस कैसे करते
हैं यह मैं आपको सिखा दूंगा स्टैग
एनालिसिस क्या होता है जो इंफॉर्मेशन हाइड
की गई थी उसको कैसे हम एक्टैक करते हैं तो
स्टार्ट करते हैं अपने टॉपिक को तो डोंट
वरी तो सबको आई होप की विजिबल होगी क्लियर
होगी और एक बार फिर से मुझे बता दीजिए
सबको मेरी आवाज लाउड एंड क्लियर
है दे ओनली 29 स्टूडेंट्स
ओ माय गॉड आप लोगों का कुछ नहीं हो
सकता 27
ओके तो स्टार्ट करते हैं सबसे पहले स्टग
ग्राफी होता क्या है स्टग ग्राफी इ द आर्ट
ऑफ हाइडिल मैसेज इनसाइड अनदर मीडिया दैट
इज कॉल्ड स्टेग्रिड
ग्राफी है यह पिछले 2500 सा से भी पहले
यूज पहले से ही इसको यूज किया जा रहा है
फर ओवर 2500 यर्स से भी पहले इसको यूज
किया जा रहा है इसको यूज करने के तरीके
अलग-अलग हो सकते हैं अलग-अलग तरीकों से या
अलग-अलग लोगों के द्वारा इसका यूज किया जा
रहा है इट हैज बीन यूज्ड इन गवर्नमेंट
डिप्लोमेटिक पर्सनल एंड इ इंटेलेक्चुअल
प्रॉपर्टी एप्लीकेशंस अमंग अदर्स ओके तो
बेसिकली गवर्नमेंट गवर्नमेंट में आपकी
इंटेलिजेंस एजेंसीज है चाहे आपकी फिर
मिलिट्री है या आपके फिर स्पाई हैं तो ये
सब क्या कर रहे हैं डायरेक्टली और
इनडायरेक्टली क्या करते हैं स्टेग्रिड
कोड या सीक्रेट इंफॉर्मेशन
को लीक होने से बचाने के लिए बाकी आप
पर्सनल तरीके से आज नाउ एडेज साइबर अटैक्स
में मैं भी इसका काफी यूज किया जाता है तो
अलग-अलग तरीकों से अलग-अलग लोगों के
द्वारा इसका यूज किया जाता है
बेसिकली मींस टेक्नोग्राफी इज ए कांसेप्ट
दैट रेफर्स टू ए वैरायटी ऑफ प्रोसेसेस दैट
कंसील ए मैसेज इनसाइड एन ऑब्जेक्ट इन सच ए
वे दैट द कंसील्ड मैसेज इज नॉट विजिबल टू
द ऑब्जर्वर बेसिकली यह एक ऐसी प्रोसेस है
जिसके अंदर आप क्या करते हो किसी एक
ऑब्जेक्ट के अंदर अपना कोई सीक्रेट कोड या
सीक्रेट मैसेज हाइड आउट करते हो और अपने
रिसीवर के पास भेज देते हो जो तो एक
नॉर्मल यूजर या विदाउट एनालिस्ट के उसको
देख पाना बहुत मुश्किल है उसको आप देख
नहीं
पाओगे द वर्ड स्टेग्रिड
स्टेग्रिड
ग्राफी जो शब्द है वह ग्रीक वर्ड से लिया
गया है जो पहले होता था स्टग ग्राफिया इट
इज अ कॉमिनेशन ऑफ स्टग एंड
ग्राफिया जो किसका कॉमिनेशन है स्टैग्नर
ग्राफिया स्टग का मतलब होता है कवर्ड और
कंसील्ड इज रिप्रेजेंटेड बाय वर्ड स्टग
एंड ग्राफिया मींस राइटिंग ओके मतलब किसी
ऑब्जेक्ट के अंदर चाहे व आपका किसी भी
मीडिया फाइल्स या टेक्स्ट ऑडियो वीडियो के
अंदर किसी सीक्रेट इंफॉर्मेशन को हाइड
करना कवर करना लिखना क्या आपका स्टग
ग्राफी है ओके
नाउ दे डिफरेंस बिटवीन क्रिप्टोग्राफी एंड
स्टेग्रिड होता क्या है अगर स्टेग्रिड
करता हूं कि क्रिप्टोग्राफी और टेगो
ग्राफी होते क्या है दोनों क्या है थोड़ा
सा डिफरेंस दोनों में इन क्रिप्टोग्राफी
मैसेज स्ट्रक्चर अल्टर्ड बट स्टेग्रिड
स्ट्रक्चर नॉट अल्टर्ड एंड इट डज नॉट चेंज
यहां चांस लिख दिया बाय चांस बट डज नॉट
चेंज रहेगा तो क्रिप्टोग्राफी के अंदर
क्या होता है कि जो भी मै मैसेज होता है
या जो भी टेक्स्ट होता है उसको क्या कर
दिया जाता है बदल दिया जाता है अल्टरेशन
परफॉर्म किया जाता है उसके जिसको हम बोलते
हैं साइफर टेक्स्ट में लेकिन स्टेग्रिड
जिस फॉर्म में है टेक्स्ट की फॉर्म में है
इमेज की फॉर्म में है वो एज इट इज रहता है
बट उसके अंदर इंफॉर्मेशन को हाइड कर दिया
जाता है बट इन स्टेग्रिड
पैटर्न और स्ट्रक्चर गोट चेंज अकॉर्डिंग
टू द एल्गोरिथम्स द सेंडर चेंज इट्स
कैरेक्टर्स टू सम अननोन पैटर्स और रिप्लेस
सम कैरेक्टर्स यूजिंग इंक्रिप्शन
एल्गोरिथम्स एंड की इट इज कॉल्ड साइफर
टेक्स्ट बेसिकली क्या करता है कि जो
क्रिप्टोग्राफी के अंदर कोई भी सेंडर्स है
या व क्या करता है कि प्लेन टेक्स्ट को
साइफर टेक्स्ट के अंदर कन्वर्ट करता है
विद द हेल्प ऑफ सम एल्गोरिथम्स जैसे कि एई
डीएस विद अब ये क्या करते हैं ये एक की की
हेल्प से परफॉर्म किया जाता है ओके और ये
इंक्रिप्शन होता क्या है डिक्रिप्शन क्या
होता है एएस क्या होता है डीएस क्या होता
है आई विल एक्सप्लेन इन द क्रिप्टोग्राफी
सेक्शन एंड देन इट सेंड टू द रिसीवर एंड
व्हेन रिसीवर इज रिसीवड द साइफर टेक्स्ट
इट डिक्रिप्ट यूजिंग द सेम एल्गोरिथम्स
एंड की दैट यूज टू इनक्रिप्ट एंड देन द
रिसीवर एबल टू रीड द कंटेंट बेसिकली होता
क्या है क्रिप्टोग्राफी के अंदर पहले
मैसेज को क्या प्लेन टेक्स्ट मैसेज को फॉर
एग्जांपल एस एल्गोरिथम की हेल्प से एसडीएस
एल्गोरिथम की हेल्प से क्या करते हैं उसको
हम सिमिट्रिक एल्गोरिथम बोल सकते हो उसको
क्या करते हैं हम इंक्रिप्ट करते हैं विद
द हेल्प ऑफ ए की मतलब एक चाबी की हेल्प से
फिर उसको हम क्या है रिसीवर के पास भेज
देते हैं और जब उसको रिसीवर एंड पर रिसीव
किया जाता है तो रिसीवर क्या करता है उस
की की हेल्प से उस मैसेज को डिक्रिप्ट
करता है जो आपका साइफर टेक्स था ना उसको
डिक्रिप्ट करता है और उस कंटेंट को रीड कर
लेता है दिस वल सिनेरियो इज नोन एज
क्रिप्टोग्राफी जिसको हम क्रिप्टोग्राफी
बोलते हैं दिस इज सीक्रेट राइटिंग जिसको
हम बोलते हैं सीक्रेट राइटिंग द अटैकर हु
गिव्स अनऑथराइज्ड एक्सेस टू द
क्रिप्टोग्राफी इज कॉल्ड क्रिप्ट एनालिसिस
अभी जो अटैकर्स है जो क्रिप्टोग्राफी के
ऊपर एनालिसिस करते हैं और अनऑथराइज्ड
एक्सेस लेने की कोशिश करते हैं या की को
फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश करते हैं या की
को आईडिया लगाते हैं कि ओके की जनरेशन ऐसे
हो रहा होगा या वी की का तो उसको हम बोलते
हैं क्रिप्ट एनालिसिस उस टर्म को हम क्या
बोलते हैं क्रिप्ट एनालिसिस जो अटैकर के
द्वारा परफॉर्म किया जाता है
क्रिप्टोग्राफी स्पोर्ट्स टू अचीव फ्यू
मेन सिक्योरिटी प्रिंसिपल्स
कॉन्फिडेंशियल्टी ऑथेंटिकेशन इंटीग्रिटी
एंड नॉन रिपीटेशंस आर देम ओके जो
क्रिप्टोग्राफी परफॉर्म की जाती है वो इन
कुछ कॉन्फिडेंस ऑथेंटिकेशन इंटीग्रिटी एंड
नॉन रेपुटेशंस को मेंटेन करने के लिए
क्रिप्टोग्राफी का यूज किया जाता है अभी
जो क्रिप्टोग्राफी यूज करती है तो अगर
उसके बीच में जो आपका टैकर्स है अगर उस
टेक्स्ट को देखता भी है तो एक साइफर
टेक्स्ट होता है जो उसको समझ में नहीं आता
तो दिस इज द केस ऑफ क्रिप्टोग्राफी नाउ
लेट्स टॉक अबाउट स्टेग्रिड
बट इन स्टेग्रिड
टेक्स्ट नॉट गेट इनटू एनी चेंजेज जो जो भी
प्लेन टेक्स्ट है या जो प्लेन इमेज है
उसके अंदर कोई भी चेंज नहीं किया जाता
इट्स अवेलेबल एज इट इज बट यूजिंग स्टेक
ग्राफिक मेथड इट्स हाइड इनसाइड नॉन
सीक्रेट फाइल अभी क्या करते हैं कि इसके
अंदर हम किसी एक फाइल को नॉन सीक्रेट भी
हो सकते है सीक्रेट फाइल उसको क्या करते
हैं हम हाइड करते हैं देर इज नो
इंक्रिप्शन और डिक्रिप्शन टू द सीक्रेट
प्लेन टेक्स्ट फाइल दिस इज कवर्ड द
राइटिंग ओके इसका कोई भी इंक्रिप्शन और
डिक्रिप्शन नहीं किया जाता प्लेन टेक्स्ट
फाइल का इन केस ऑफ स्टेग्रिड
ग्राफी इट्स सपोज टू अचीव ओनली टू
सिक्योरिटी प्रिंसिपल्स इन नेम्स इट इज
कॉन्फिडेंस एंड ऑथेंटिकेशंस ओके स्टेग्रिड
ही सिक्योरिटी प्रिंसिपल अचीव करते हैं एक
तो कॉन्फिडेंशियल और ऑथेंटिकेशन कैसे
कॉन्फिडेंशियल मींस ओनली ऑथराइज यूजर्स
कैन सी द डाटा एंड ऑथेंटिकेशन इज मोस्ट
मली इंपोर्टेंट इन ट्रांसमिटेड डाटा बिकॉज
डाटा शुड ऑलवेज सेंड एंड रिसीव टू द
ऑथराइज्ड पर्सनल ओनली दैट मींस डाटा शुड
वैलिड एंड इट शुड सेंड बाय करेक्ट सेंडर
एंड इट शुड रिसीव टू द करेक्ट रिसीवर इस
तरीके से कॉन्फिडेंशियल और आपकी
ऑथेंटिकेशन को मेंटेन किया जाता है
क्योंकि जिस डाटा के जिस जो सेंडर जिसके
पास भेजना चाहता है वही उसको क्या करता है
रिसीव करता है बीच में अगर उसको अटैकर
कैप्चर भी करता है अगर फॉर एग्जांपल उसको
नॉलेज नहीं है तो उस इमेज को उस टेक्स्ट
को देख के आइडेंटिफिकेशन
टेक्नोग्राफी किसी को कोई डाउट है तो
मुझसे अभी पूछ सकता है चैट
में
रिपीट देखिए क्रिप्टोग्राफी के केस में
क्या होता है कि जो जो भी प्लेन टेक्स्ट
है या जो भी इमेज है उसके साथ कोई भी
छेड़छाड़ नहीं की मतलब स्टग ग्राफी के केस
में उसके केस कोई भी छेड़छाड़ नहीं की
जाती है लेकिन क्रिप्टोग्राफी के केस में
क्या होता है कि जो भी प्लेन टेक्स्ट होगा
या जो भी इमेज है उनको या तो हम कंप्रेस
करते हैं या हम क्या करते हैं प्लेन टैक्स
को इंक्रिप्ट करते हैं इंक्रिप्ट करके
साइफर टैक्स में कन्वर्ट करते हैं बेसिकली
कहने का मतलब क्या है क्रिप्टोग्राफी में
आप क्या करते हो इंक्रिप्शन करते हो और
सेंडर रिसीवर साइड में डिक्रिप्शन करते हो
विद द हेल्प ऑफ की टेगो ग्राफी के केस में
ऐसा कुछ नहीं होता आप जैसी फाइल भेज रहे
हो एज इट इज भेज सकते हो लेकिन आप अपनी
फेशन उस फाइल के अंदर हाइड कर देते हो
पीडीएफ फाइल के अंदर ऑडियो फाइल के अंदर
वीडियो फाइल के अंदर या आप टेक्स्ट फाइल
के अंदर क्योंकि इसमें आपको इंक्रिप्शन और
डिक्रिप्शन करने की जरूरत नहीं है एवरी
नाउ अभी समझ में आ
गया
बताइए अभी समझ में आ गया
आपको
ओके तो अभी बात करते हैं हम देख द
एडवांटेज ऑफ द स्टेग्रिड
इज इन क्रिप्टोग्राफी द सीक्रेट इज नॉन
रीडेबल बट इट इज बट इट विजिबल टू अटैकर्स
मे बी इट अनब्रेकेबल अकॉर्डिंग टू द
एल्गोरिथम्स ओके बट इन स्टेग्रिड
कैन नॉट बी विजिबल सो अटैकर्स और
अनऑथराइज्ड पर्सन डज नॉट नो इज देयर हैव
सीक्रेट और नॉट समझ में आया कि
क्रिप्टोग्राफी के केस में जो भी सीक्रेट
फाइल्स है वो नॉन रीडेबल होती है ओके अगर
उसको अटैकर देख भी लेगा तो वह पता नहीं कर
पाएगा अगर विजिबल होती है लेकिन पता नहीं
कर पाएगा यह क्या चीज है क्योंकि वो एक
जब्रज फॉर्म में होगी लेकिन स्टेग्रिड
बल हो सकती है लेकिन वह यह आईडिया नहीं
लगा पाएगा इस फाइल के अंदर सीक्रेट है या
नहीं है
ओके
नाउ ट आप अभी स्टैग एनालिसिस क्या होता है
स्टैगो ग्राफी तो मैंने बता दिया कि
स्टैगो ग्राफी एक ऐसी प्रोसेस है जिसमें
आप क्या करते हो इंफॉर्मेशन को हाइड करते
हो किसकी फॉर्म में मीडिया की फॉर्म में
चाहे वह आपका पीडीएफ फाइल हो ऑडियो फाइल
हो इमेज फाइल हो या वीडियो फाइल हो उसके
अंदर आप इफर्म सीक्रेट इंफॉर्मेशन को हाइड
कर देते हो लेकिन स्टैग एनालिसिस क्या
होता है जो आज का हमारा इंपोर्टेंट टॉपिक
है स्टैग एनालिसिस इज द प्रोसेस ऑफ
डिटेक्टिंग द हिडन डाटा च आर क्रेस्टेड
यूजिंग स्टेग्रिड
एंड स्टग एनालिसिस आर एनालॉग्स टू
इंक्रिप्शन एंड डिक्रिप्शन यह मैंने सिर्फ
आपको समझाने के लिए यूज़ किया हुआ है कि
स्टैगो ग्राफ को समझी आप इंक्रिप्शन है और
स्टैग एनालिसिस को आप समझिए वह डिक्रिप्शन
है अगर आपको समझ में आ रहा हो तो बस यह
एग्जांपल के लिए है बट ऐसा नहीं है
स्टेग्रिड ने जो भी इंफॉर्मेशन आपने हाइड
की थी किसी भी फाइल के अंदर उस फाइल को
एनालाइज करना उस इंफॉर्मेशन को
एक्सट्रैक्ट करना कहलाता है स्टैग
एनालिसिस स्टैग एनालिसिस फॉलो द सेट ऑफ
टेक्निक एंड मेथड्स दैट आर यूज टू डिटेक्ट
द प्रेजेंस ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन एंबेडेड इन
डिजिटल प्रोजेक्ट्स एंड टू एक्सट्रैक्ट
दिस इंफॉर्मेशन इफ इट इज पॉसिबल और स्टैक
एनालिसिस का मतलब क्या होता है कि यह क्या
करता है कि कुछ सेट ऑफ टेक्निक्स होते हैं
कुछ मेथड्स होते हैं कुछ टूल्स है होते
हैं जिनकी हेल्प से हम क्या करते हैं वो
छुपाई हुई इंफॉर्मेशन जो इंफॉर्मेशन हमने
ने हाइड कि है किसी भी फाइल के अंदर
डिजिटल ऑब्जेक्ट के अंदर उसको एक्सट्रैक्ट
करने करने के करने के लिए ओके अगर वो
पॉसिबल हुई तो स्टैग एनालिसिस ये कैसी
प्रोसेस है ओके तो ये क्या करती है कुछ
टेक्निक्स होती है स्टैग एनालिसिस की थी
टू फोर फेज होती है स्टेजेज होती है जो हम
हमेशा क्या है परफॉर्म करते हैं स्टैग
एनालिसिस के केस में अपनी इसी हाइडिंट को
फाइंड आउट करने के लिए ओके उसके लिए कुछ
टूल्स होते हैं जिनकी हेल्प से हम ये
इंफॉर्मेशन
ये इंफॉर्मेशन एक्सट्रैक्ट करते हैं तो
स्टैक एनालिसिस सबको क्लियर है कि अब
स्टैग एनालिसिस क्या होता है जो हमारा आज
का टॉपिक है
ओके तो
चलो तो सबसे पहले अभी अभी हम क्या करते
हैं स्टैग एनालिसिस का जो हमारा
प्रैक्टिकल है वह परफॉर्म करते हैं उसके
बीच में जो भी टूल्स होंगे उनको एक एक
करके उनकी जो बोल सकते हो चीट ट है मेरे
पास उसको हम यूज करेंगे कुछ यूजफुल
आर्टिकल्स है मैं आपको प्रोवाइड कर दूंगा
तो अभी सीटीएफ परफॉर्म करते हैं जिसका नाम
बुकली 99 ओके तो स्टार्ट करें अपने सीटीएफ
को विद द हेल्प ऑफ स्टैग एनालिसिस हाउ टू
फाइंड हाउ टू एक्सप्लोइट अवर मशीन या हाउ
टू गैदर ऑल द इंफॉर्मेशन च आर नेसेसरी या
रिलेटेड टू द मशीन एंड बेस्ड ऑन दैट
इंफॉर्मेशन वी शुड एक्सप्लोइट द मशीन एंड
गेन द एक्सेस
एवरीवन ओके चलो तो लेट्स गो टू आवर काली
नेक्स
मशीन आई थिंक इट इ बल टू एवरीवन दिस इज
आवर ब्रुकलिन
99 नाउ लेट्स स्टार्ट अवर मशीन बिफोर
स्टार्टिंग द मशीन आई विल स्टार्ट माय ओपन
वीपीएन तो सड सुडो से पहले सीडी
नलोड ओके वीपीएन हम स् हो चुका है नाउ
न्यू टैब ओके इसको हम एक बार रिनेम कर
देते
हैं ओके नाउ स्टार्ट द मशीन
बुकली 99 दिस इज द सीटीएफ नेम ब्रुकलिन
99 इट इज वेरी वेरी इजी मशीन एक्चुअल में
आपने अगर दो सीटी परफॉर्म किया ना हमारे
पिक पिकल रिक और जो हमने लास्ट क्लास में
बाउंट हैकर किया था तो अगर उसके बेस पर
आपने इस मशीन को सॉल्व करोगे ना तो
हार्डली 10 टू 15 मिनट में आप इस मशीन को
सॉल्व कर दोगे सच में इट इज वेरी वेरी इजी
मशीन ओके तो देखिए वी गोट एन आईपी एड्रेस
जस्ट हमें दो फ्लैग फाइंड आउट करने हैं एक
यूजर फ्लैग और रूट फ्लैग तो देखते हैं
क्या मिलता है इसमें दिस इज आवर आईपी
एड्रेस नाउ सबसे पहले हम क्या करते हैं
मशीन को आप सबको पता है तो बार-बार मैं
रिपीट नहीं करूंगा तो सबसे पहले मशीन को
पिंग करते हैं और इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट
करने की कोशिश करते हैं कि मशीन इज अलाइव
और नॉट ओके मशीन इज लाइव इट इज अ लिनक्स
मशीन जो हम फिर से अपना एक आईडिया रफ
आईडिया लगाते हैं बेस्ड ऑन द टीटीएल
वैल्यू ए मैप परफॉर्म करते हैं सर्विस
वर्जन डिटेक्शन करते हैं देन उसके बाद मैं
परफॉर्म करता हूं कि ओके सर्विस वर्जन
डिटेक्शन करते हैं और टारगेट आईपीयू
एड्रेस यह रहा
यह बहुत इजी है
लेकिन बेस्ड ऑन द स्टग ग्राफी मे बी मोस्ट
ऑफ द स्टूडेंट डोंट नो तो आज इसको
एक्सप्लेन करेंगे टेक्नोग्राफी की हेल्प
तो दे थ्री पोर्ट्स आर ओपन सिमिलर टू सिमर
लाइक बिफोर द लब्स व सोल्ड इन द बाउंट
हैकर
बाउंटीज थे तो सेम पोर्ट नंबर 21 पोर्ट
नंबर 22 पोर्ट नंबर 80 आर अवेलेबल एसस के
क्रेडेंशियल हमारे पास नहीं है एफटीपी को
हम चेक कर सकते कि एनोनिमस जो एफटीपी
एनोनिमस जो वटी अवेलेबल तो नहीं है उसके
लिए हम क्या परफॉर्म करेंगे एन मैप हाइ फन
सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन चलता रहेगा या हाइ
फन हाइन
स्क्रिप्ट हाइन हाइ फन स्क्रिप्ट देन उसके
बाद एफटीपी
अननोन देन उसके बाद हम क्या करते हैं
टारगेट आईपी ट
एंटर तो इससे हमें पता चल जाएगा कि जो
हमारा
टारगेट मशीन है वह एफटीपी से एनोनिमस लॉग
इन होने के लिए मिस कन्फर तो नहीं है और
हमें पता चल गया कि एफटीपी एनोनिमस लॉगिन
इज अलाउड कोड सोन सो यह रहा तो अभी हम
क्या करते हैं अलाउड है तो एफटीपी लॉगिन
कैसे कर सकते हैं सबको पता है
तो एफटीपी से लॉग इन करने के लिए एफटीपी
उसके बाद क्रेडेंशियल ऑफ द मशीन न सॉरी
आईपी एड्रेस ऑफ द मशीन देन
एनोनिमस पासवर्ड की हमें जरूरत नहीं इसके
लिए क्योंकि यह मिस कन्फर है यह कैसे हमने
कैसे पता किया विद द हेल्प ऑफ एफटीपी अनन
स्क्रिप्ट तो अभी हम क्या करते हैं लिस्ट
आउट करते हैं एल एस एंटरिंग ओके यहां पर
एक फाइल मिली हमें रीड राइट रीड उसके बाद
फाइल का नाम है नोट टू जक एक्सटी तो इसको
हम डाउनलोड कर लेते हैं अपनी मशीन के अंदर
गेट नोट टू जक डटी
एक्टी हिट एंटर और सक्सेसफुली डाउनलोड
किया अभी हम इससे आउट कर लेते हैं अपने
आपको को तो अभी एलस हमारे पास फाइल कहां
पर है नोट
टू नोटू जटी एक्सटी तो उसको हम कैट आट कैट
करते
हैं हिट एंटर तो इसके अंदर लिखा है कि
फ्रॉम
एमी जक प्लीज चेंज योर पासवर्ड इट इज टू
वीक एंड होल्ट विल बी मेड इफ समवन हैक
इनटू द
नाना शायद किसी को समझ समझ पा रहे हो कि
क्या चल रहा है क्या बोल क्या कहने की
कोशिश कर रही है देखो यह बोल रहा है कि
फ्रॉम एमी एमी से एक मैसेज है एमी कोई एक
यूजर नेम है कोई भी एक इसमें हम कस्टमर
बोल सकते हैं क्लाइंट बोल सकते हैं या कोई
भी यूजर हो सकता है जक प्लीज चेंज पासवर्ड
एमी जैक को बोल रहा है कि भाई तुम अपना
पासवर्ड चेंज कर लो वह बहुत वीक पासवर्ड
है होल्ट विड बी मेड इफ समवन हैक इनटू द
नाना मे बी इससे हम सोच सकते कि एमी मैसेज
पास कर रहा है जैक को जैक भाई अपना
पासवर्ड चेंज कर ले बहुत कमजोर होल्ट जो
हमारा बॉस हो सकता है सुपरवाइजर हो सकता
है वह पागल हो जाएगा अगर हमारे वीक
पासवर्ड की वजह से मशीन हैक हो गई तो शायद
इसका मतलब यही है तो य पर तीन यूजर नेम है
एमी जैक और होल्ट बट यहां पर आपने नोटिस
किया होगा कि जैक का पासवर्ड वीक है जैक
का यहां
पर पासवर्ड वीक है मतलब क्लियर है कि जो
कॉमन वर्ड लिस्ट होगी जैक का पासवर्ड
उसमें मिल जाएगा तो सबसे पहले आपको पता है
हम क्या परफॉर्म करते हैं कि ब्रूट फोर्स
परफॉर्म करेंगे किसका जैक का पासवर्ड
फाइंड आउट करने के लिए यह आप लोगों का
टास्क था कि जक का पासवर्ड कैसे फाइंड आउट
करोगे और एक और चीज है कि इसके लिए आपको
जो वर्ड लिस्ट यूज करोगे उस वर्डलिस्ट का
नाम है यह रहा यहां पर गट up.com पर यह
रहा आपकी वड लिस्ट रहेगी रोटी एक्सटी रोक
डटी एक्सटी एक वर्डलिस्ट है यह
वाली सर्च मारोगे तो आपको मिल जाएगा यह
रहा रोक एक्सटी यह वाली वर्ड लिस्ट आपको
क्या करनी है डाउनलोड करनी है इस वर्ड
लिस्ट को यूज करना इस लैब के
लिए तो सिंपली मैं आपको लिंक प्रोवाइड कर
देता हूं अभी के लिए और गो टू आवर
चैट
पेस्ट यह वर्ड लिस्ट है आप सिंपली आपको
क्या करना है अपने काली लिनेक्स के अंदर
डाउनलोड कर लेना है अगर अवेलेबल नहीं है
तो आजकल तो य बाय डिफॉल्ट मिलता ही है
आपको वड लिस्ट के अंदर मिलेगा बट डाउनलोड
कर लिया हमने नेक्स्ट अभी आपका टास्क यहां
पर क्या है कि आपको इसके ऊपर बट फर्स्ट
ट्राई करना है यूजर नेम आपके पास है जक और
wordlist.txt को आपने यूज करना है .
tt8 को चेक करते हैं कि पोर्ट 80 पर क्या
अवेलेबल है तो पोर्ट 80 पर जो अवेलेबल है
उसको हम चेक करने के लिए एक बार आईपी
एड्रेस लेते हैं मशीन का कॉपी द टारगेट
आईपी देन
पेस्ट हिट
एंटर अब यह देखो यहां पर एक पोस्टर है
बकली 99 और यहां पर कुछ लिखा हुआ है तो
अभी मैं जूम आउट कर देता हूं इसको सो दैट
कि आपको क्लियर हो जाएगा ये
रहा नहीं मैं एक बार जूम कर देता हूं ये
रहा अगर आप देखोगे दिस एग्जांपल क्रिएट ए
फुल पेज बैकग्राउंड इमेज ट्राई टू रिसाइट
द ब्राउजर विंडो टू सी हाउ इट ऑलवेज बी
कवर द फुल स्क्रीन व्हेन स्क्रोल टू टॉप
एंड दैट इ स्केल नाइसली ऑल अन स्क्रीन अभी
यहां पर पर आपको शायद कुछ नहीं देखने को
मिल रहा ना तो जो नीचे टेक्स्ट लिखा है
उसके अंदर कोई इंफॉर्मेशन है ना ही आपको
यह इमेज अभी इमेज को हम क्या करते हैं
राइट क्लिक करते हैं और सेव कर लेते हैं
तो सेव पेज नहीं सेव इमेज करेंगे पहले हम
इसको क्या करते हैं राइट क्लिक ओपन इन
न्यू टैब न टैब ने ओपन किया यहां पर क्या
बकलिन 99 जेपीजी यहां पर अलग से कोई भी
डिक्शनरी हमें यहां पर देख डायरेक्टली
देखने को नहीं मिल रही हम य करते हैं सेव
इमेज एज और अभी के लिए हम इसको डाउनलोड के
अंदर रखते हैं बुकली 99 के नाम से तो अभी
शॉर्ट फॉर्म करते इसको सेव इमेज को हमने
सेव कर लिया क्योंकि अभी हम क्या करेंगे
यहां पर स्टैग एनालिसिस परफॉर्म करेंगे
बेस्ड ऑन द इमेज तो अभी इसको सेव कर लेते
हैं सबसे पहले हम चेक कर लेते हैं अभी
र अभी क्या चेक करना हमें दूसरी
फाइल बताइए
बताइए
बताइए अभी मुझे वेबसाइट के केस में और
क्या चेक करना है
बताइए बताइए
यार या रोबोट एक्सटी
रोबोट्स डटी एक्सटी फाइल हमने यहां पर चेक
करनी है हिट एंटर्स रोबोट टी एक्सटी फाइल
नॉट अवेलेबल यह इंफॉर्मेशन हमारे पास भी
है ओके तो नॉट यूजफुल इंफॉर्मेशन हमें कुछ
भी नहीं मिला अभी हम क्या करते हैं राइट
क्लिक व्यू पेज सोर्स यहां पर कुछ मिलता
हमें ओके ओके ओके दिस एग्जांपल हैव यू
हियर एवर यर्ड ऑफ स्टेनोग्राफी मतलब य
हमें कमेंट
में एक हिंट दे रहा है हमें बोल रहा है कि
क कभी आपने टेक्नोग्राफी के बारे में सुना
है यह हमें हिंट दे रहा है तो ओके तो हम
टेक्नोग्राफी परफॉर्म करेंगे कैसे परफॉर्म
करेंगे आई विल एक्सप्लेन तो अभी पोर्ट
नंबर 80 पर हमें एक इमेज मिली है इमेज का
हमें स्टैग एनालिसिस करना है उसके अलावा
जो टेक्स्ट मिला है टेक्स्ट के अंदर कुछ
भी खास नहीं हमें मिला रोट डटी एकटी फाइल
के अंदर कुछ नहीं मिला क्योंकि वह फाइल्स
अवेलेबल ही नहीं है और उसके अलावा अभी
हमें नेक्स्ट काम क्या करना चाहिए नेक्स्ट
बताइए नेक्स्ट बताइए नेक्स्ट हमें क्या
करना है नेक्स्ट हमें डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट
फोर्स परफॉर्म करना है विद द हेल्प ऑफ
डरबस्टर ये आप लोगों का काम था कि
डायरेक्टली ब्रूट फोर्स परफॉर्म करना और
हाइड्रा टूल की हेल्प से ब्रूट फोर्स
परफॉर्म करना वहां पर पासवर्ड फाइंड आउट
करना है और डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्स से
आपको क्या फाइंड आउट करना है कि और भी कोई
डायरेक्टरी या वेब पेजेस अवेलेबल तो नहीं
है ओके तो अभी मैं आपको सिखाता हूं कि
स्टैग एनालिसिस कैसे करते हैं ओके तो
क्लियर करते हैं अभी हम स्क्रीन को और अभी
डाउनलोड डायरेक्टरी के अंदर है तो हमारे
पास जो इमेज है यहां पर इमेज का नाम था
हमारे पास
डाउनलोडस और पोर्टल ड जेपीजी रके इमेज
बुकली 99 जेपीजी यह हमारी इमेज है बुकली
99 जेपीजी हमारी इमेज है य वाली हमें इसका
क्या करना है अभी टैग एनालिसिस करना है तो
स्टैग एनालिसिस करने के लिए सबसे पहले हम
परफॉर्म करते
हैं मेटा डाटा कलेक्शन मेटा डाटा
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करते हैं ओके तो उसके
लिए हम एक टूल यूज करते हैं एजिप टूल कौन
सा टूल यूज करते हैं हम एजिप टूल का यूज
करते हैं सबसे पहले हम तो
एजिप एफ होगा टूल ओके मे बी हा एफ टूल
एजिप टूल देन उसके बाद
बुकली बुकली नाड जेपीजी अभी हिट एंटर
अभी यह जो टूल क्या करता है यह टूल आपको
इमेज का मेटा डाटा एक्सट्रैक्ट करके फाइंड
आउट करके आपकी स्क्रीन के सामने रिजल्ट
में शो करता है तो किसी भी इमेज का किसी
भी अ वीडियो फाइल का यह क्या करता है मेटा
डाटा फाइंड आउट करता है किसी को पता है
मेटा डाटा क्या होता है व्हाट इज मेटा
डाटा
किसी को पता है कि मेटा डाटा क्या होता
है डाटा अबाउट
डेटा एनी वन प्लीज बताइए मेटा डाटा क्या
होता है
मैं एक्सप्लेन करता हूं स्लाइड की स्लाइड
की हेल्प से उसके बाद आगे बढ़ेंगे हम एक
मिनट अ दीज आर द स्लाइड्स
ओके एजिप मेटा डाटा ओके जो आपका एजिप टूल
है वह आपके एजिप मेटा डाटा को शो करता है
तो यह एजिप मेटा डाटा क्या होता है एप का
मतलब होता है एक्सचेंज बल इमेज फाइल
फॉर्मेट मेटा डाटा इज ए स्टैंडर्डाइज
फॉर्मेट एंबेडेड इन इमेज एंड वीडियो
फाइल्स डैश स्टोर इंफॉर्मेशन अबाउट द
फाइल्स क्रिएशन टेक्निकल प्रॉपर्टीज एंड
कांटेक्ट बेसिकली क्या होता है कि यह मेटा
डाटा एक स्टैंडर्डाइज फॉर्मेट होता है जो
किसी भी इमेज या ऑडियो फाइल के अंदर इंबेड
किया जाता है स्टोर किया जाता है जिसके
अंदर कौन सी इंफॉर्मेशन होता आपकी फाइल कब
क्रिएट हुई
थी कब किस फोन ने फोन ने उसको कैप्चर किया
था फोन का पिक्सेल टाइम एंड डेट स्टम इवन
उसकी लोकेशंस
और कितना मेगापिक्सल कैमरा था देन उसका
कलर्स और देन कंप्रेशन टेक्निक तो यह सारी
चीजें
उसमें इंफॉर्मेशन में अवेलेबल रहती है इट
इ ऑटोमेटिक जनरेट बाय डिवाइस लाइक कैमरा
स्मार्टफोन और सॉफ्टवेयर वन कैप्चर और
एडिटिंग मीडिया ओके एजिप मेटा डाटा मोस्ट
कॉमनली फाउंड इन फाइल फॉर्मेट लाइक
के केस में जेपीजी पीएनजी और रो फॉर्मेट
और वीडियोस के केस में एम ओवी एमपी4 और
एवी फॉर्मेट में आपको देखने को मिलता है
तो बेसिकली जो एजिप मेटा डाटा होता है जो
आपका मेटा डाटा होता है उसकी एक स्ट्रक्चर
होती है जैसे कैमरा एंड टेक्निकल डिटेल्स
में कैमरा मेक एंड मॉडल्स लेंस मॉडल शटर
स्पीड आसो सेंसिटिविटी फोकल लेंथ फ्लैश
इंफॉर्मेशन
नेक्स्ट आपकी जो इफ डेट एंड टाइम में मेटा
डाटा अबाउट व्हेन द इमेज और वीडियो वाज
डेट टेकन डेट मॉडिफाइड टाइम जोन
इंफॉर्मेशन यह सारी इंफॉर्मेशन उस मेटा
डेटा के अंदर होती है जिओलोकेशन डाटा लटटू
एंड लोंगिट्यूड
एल्टीट्यूड जीपीएस टाइम स्टैंप डायरेक्शन
ओरिएंटेशन इमेज इंफॉर्मेशन जैसे
रेजोल्यूशन फाइल फॉर्मेट कलर स्पेस
कंप्रेशन टाइप जैसे जेपीजी पीएनजी
रेजोल्यूशन क्या है फाइल फॉर्मेट क्या है
यह सारी इंफॉर्मेशन आपकी मेटा डाटा के
अंदर होती है और सॉफ्टवेयर प्रोसेसिंग इफ
े होती है जैसे सॉफ्टवेयर नेम स किस
सॉफ्टवेयर से इसको लिया गया इंफॉर्मेशन को
या इस फोटो क्लिक किया गया है देन एडिटिंग
हिस्ट्री कोई भी अगर उसको एडिट किया गया
हो देन एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव मेटा डाटा जैसे
ऑथर नेम कॉपीराइट नोटिस अगर उस रिलेटेड
कोई कॉपीराइट इंफॉर्मेशन होगी तो वह भी
आपको उसके डाटा में मिलेगी लाइसेंसिंग
इंफॉर्मेशन यह सारी की सारी चीजें आपकी
क्या है मेटा डाटा के अंदर देखने को मिलती
है किसी भी इमेज या वीडियो का
ओके सबको क्लियर
है नाउ ये एग्जांपल है जैसे कैमरा में एक
एल मॉडल i 14 लेंस देन डेट टेकन आओ ये
उसकी फोकल लेंथ जीपीएस लटटू डीपीएस
लोंगिट्यूड एल्टीट्यूड होता है मीन सी
लेवल से फाइल साइज क्या है कंप्रेशन
जेपीजी इस तरीके से आपको यह डाटा देखने को
मिलता है जो अभी हमने एजिप टूल की हेल्प
से देखा था तो क्लियर कि मेटा डाटा क्या
सबको पता चल गया एवरीवन गट क्लियर कि मेटा
डाटा का मतलब ही होता क्या है
ओके सबको समझ में आ
गया अगर आपको सबको समझ में आ गया तो अभ एक
कॉमन सेंस का यूज करना आपको अपने खुद की
और मेरे सवालों का जवाब देना है जो मैं
अभी आपसे पूछने वाला हूं
ओके आर यू रेडी गाइस कि मेटा डाटा क्या
होता है और किस टाइप टाइप की इंफॉर्मेशन
उसके अंदर देखने को मिलती है तो देखिए तो
मेरा एक सवाल है सभी से द डेवलपर ऑफ द फब
एंड ा आर सो स्मार्ट तो वई कान नोट दे
ऑटोमेटिक ऐड लोकेशन ऑफ द इमेज देखिए हम सब
फ और ा के जमाने में है और उनको हम यूज
करते हैं तो अभी देखिए वह इतनी स्मार्ट
कंपनियां है उनके जो डेवलपर्स है वो इतने
स्मार्ट है तो फिर ऑटोमेटिक जो इमेज की जो
लोकेशन उसको ऐड क्यों नहीं करते पहला सवाल
वो ऑटोमेटिक क्यों नहीं ऐड करते क्या
व्हाई कैन नोट दे जस्ट लुक एट द इमेजेस
रीड इट एंड एड द लोकेशन बाय देम सेल्स
क्यों ये जो जो भी हम फोटो क्लिक करते हैं
जब भी अपलोड करते हैं तो उस इमेज को देखकर
रीड आउट करके एनालाइज करके वो खुद से वो
लोकेशन को क्यों नहीं ऐड कर देते व्हाई
कुड नॉट फ और ा
डू इट योरसेल्फ वो खुद से क्यों नहीं करती
है सारी चीजें अभी कभी भी आपने देखा होगा
जब भी आप फोटो अपलोड करते हो या कोई भी
रील अपलोड करते हो
[संगीत]
बताइए किसी को इसका जवाब है कोई जानता
है बिकॉज ऑफ प्राइवेसी पॉलिसीज क्योंकि जब
भी आपकी कोई भी वीडियोस कोई भी फोटो को ज
अपलोड किया जाता है सोशल मीडिया प्रोफाइल
के ऊपर तो उसके मेटा डाटा को क्या कर दिया
जाता है हटा दिया जाता है डिस्ट्रॉय कर
दिया जाता है अपलोड करने से पहले इसका
कारण यह है क्योंकि अगर वह ऐसा नहीं
करेंगे तो कोई भी उनके ऊपर ड्यू टू
प्राइवेसी रीजंस केश डाल सकता है और उनके
ऊपर अगर कैश डालेगा तो क्या होगा वह कंपनी
से कंपनी से अच्छा खासा अमाउंट ले सकता है
या कंपनी को बैन करवा सकता है कंपनी पे
एलिगेशंस लगा सकता है जिससे कंपनी के
बिजनेस प इफेक्ट पड़ेगा ओके ड्यू टू
प्राइवेसी कंसर्न वो ऐसा नहीं करते इसलिए
वो ऑप्शन आप को दिया जाता है कि दैट इज
योर चॉइस कि आप इसको एक्सपोज करना चाहते
हो या नहीं चाहते इसलिए आपको कभी भी जो
मेटा डाटा की इंफॉर्मेशन होती है जो
इंपोर्टेंट मेटा डाटा है वह सारा का सारा
आपका क्या कर दिया जाता है हटा दिया जाता
है और उसकी जगह कोई डमी डाटा ऐड कर दिया
जाता है एवरीवन गट क्लियर सबको समझ में आ
गया यस बिल्कुल जिससे कोई ओसेंट परफॉर्म
ना कर सके सबको क्लियर है कि मेटा डाटा
क्या होता है क्या इंफॉर्मेशन
मिलती है
और आपको मेटा डाटा की इंफॉर्मेशन कम क्यों
मिलती है जब भी आपने अपना खुद का फोटो
खींचा होगा या अपने फोन में फोटो खींचा हो
उसके उस केस में बहुत ज्यादा इंफॉर्मेशन
होती है तो चलिए चलते हैं हम अपनी मशीन के
अंदर अभी यहां पर जो इंफॉर्मेशन आपको
देखने को मिल रही है
देखो फाइल
नेम डायरेक्टरी डॉट फाइल साइज ये रहा फाइल
मॉडिफिकेशन डेट है 2025 सोन सो ये इसका
टाइम जोन है फाइल एक्सेस डेट एंड टाइम
फाइल आई नट चेंज एंड फॉर फाइल परमिशन है
फाइल टाइप जेपीजी फाइल एक्सपेंशन जेपीजी
उसके बाद और कुछ शायद में लटटू लोंगिट्यूड
नहीं है इनकोडिंग प्रोसेस सोन सो देखो हफ
मेन कोडिंग का यूज कर रहे हैं देन कलर कटन
सी इमेज साइज मेगापिक्सल मतलब इसके अंदर
हमें कुछ खास इंफॉर्मेशन देखने को नहीं
मिल रही इसको देख के आपको लगता है कि कोई
खास इंफॉर्मेशन है मतलब यहां पर हमें कोई
भी इंफॉर्मेशन अभी सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन
नहीं मिली इसके अंदर कुछ मिला आपको
सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन आपको लगता
है इसके अंदर कोई भी सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन
नहीं है देन उसके बाद एक नेक्स्ट टूल होता
है जिसका नाम है आपका बिनवाक अभी एजिप टूल
क्या क्या इंफॉर्मेशन आपको प्रोवाइड करता
है तो मैं आपको बता देता हूं एक बार इसकी
चीट शट आपको देखनी है याय बार सीटी को
सॉल्व करते हैं उसके बाद हम देखते इसकी टट
ओके तो अभी उसके बाद हम नेक्स्ट टूल जो हम
यूज करते हैं वह होता आपका
बिनवाक बिन वक यह रहा बिन वक टूल का हम
यूज करते हैं और अभी हम मेंशन कर देते हैं
इस इमेज
को
बुकली 99 जपजी
हिट एंटर
अभी जो बिनवाक होता है यह एक फर्मवेयर
एनालिसिस टूल है देखो यहां पर कुछ भी आपको
इंफॉर्मेशन देखो डेसीमल जीरो हेक्सा
डेसीमल जीरो डिस्क्रिप्शन क्या जेपीजी
इमेज डाटा स्टैंडर्ड
1.01 मतलब यहां पर भी आपको कोई भी
इंफॉर्मेशन देखने को नहीं मिली अभी बिन वक
क्या होता है बिन वक एक फर्मवेयर एनालिसिस
टूल होता है फर्मवेयर एनालिसिस टूल होता
है ओके जब भी फॉर एग्जांपल आप एक फॉरेंसिक
एनालिस्ट हो अगर आपको फॉरेंसिक एनालिसिस
करना है किसका
[संगीत]
इंस्टॉल नहीं होता यह फर्मवेयर का यूज
करते हैं इनके ऊपर जो प्रोटोकॉल यूज किया
जाता है वह बहुत ही लाइट वेट प्रोटोकॉल का
यूज किया जाता है फुल ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम हम
इनके ऊपर इंस्टॉल नहीं कर सकते बिकॉज ऑफ
दैट रीजन ड्यूरिंग फॉरेंसिक एनालिसिस वी
ऑन आईओटी डीआई वी परफॉर्म फर्मवेयर
एनालिसिस ओके उनके ऊपर हम क्या करते हैं
फर्मवेयर एनालिसिस परफॉर्म करते हैं और
फर्मवेयर एनालिसिस परफॉर्म करने के लिए एक
टूल होता है जिसका नाम बिनवाक है इस टूल
का हम यूज कर देते हैं लेकिन दिस टूल इ
नॉट ओनली फॉर द फर्मवेयर एनालिसिस हम इसको
बिनवाक टूल को अपने स्टग ग्राफी के केस
में भी हम यूज कर सकते हैं जो इमेजेस है
उसके डाटा को एनालिस करने के लिए भी हम
बिनवाक टूल का यूज कर सकते हैं अगर इस
रिलेटेड आपको आर्टिकल चाहिए तो मेरे पास
एक वेरी गुड आर्टिकल्स है जो आप परफॉर्म
कर
सके यह एक आर्टिकल है मीडियम का आर्टिकल
है मैं आपको लिंक भेज रहा हूं आप इसको
क्या कर सकते
हो कंट्रोल व ट टर यह एक आर्टिकल है इससे
आप क्या कर सकते हो गो थ्रू कर सकते हो कि
यह बिनवाक टू जो टूल्स है कैसे काम करता
है डिटेल्स में इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड की गई
है अगर आपको यह भी इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए कि
फर्मवेयर क्या होता है देखो फर्मवेयर क्या
होता है फर्मवेयर इज अ फॉर्म ऑफ माइक्रो
कोड और प्रोग्राम एंबेडेड इन टू हार्डवेयर
डिवाइस टू हेल्प देम ऑपरेट इफेक्टिवली
हार्डवेयर लाइक कैमरा मोबाइल फोनस नेटवर्क
कोड्स ऑप्टिकल ड्राइव्स प्रिंटर्स राउटर्स
स्कैनर टेलीविजन रिमोट्स रिलाई ऑन द
फर्मवेयर बिल्ट इन टू देयर मेमोरी टू
फंक्शन स्मूथली ओके हार्डवेयर से
कम्युनिकेट करने के लिए नॉर्मली हम क्या
करते हैं फर्मवेयर का यूज करते हैं जैसे
कि आपकी वाशिंग मशीनस है उनके ऊपर कोई
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम काम नहीं करता वहां पर भी
फर्मवेयर काम करता है जैसे कि एग्जांपल्स
क्या है बायोस है बेसिक इनपुट आउटपुट
सिस्टम के बीच में भी हम क्या करते हैं
फर्मवेयर यूज करते हैं एक्सटेंसिबल
फर्मवेयर इंटरफेस यह भी है तो हर जगह क्या
हम फर्मवेयर यूज करते हैं जब हार्डवेयर से
सॉफ्टवेयर क कनेक्शन बनाने के लिए देखिए
व्हेन ए डिवाइस स्विच जज ऑन द फर्मवेयर
इंस्ट्रक्ट द प्रोसेसर टू इनिशिएटिव
ऑपरेट मल्टीपल फॉर्म्स ऑफ फर्मवेयर टू
परफॉर्म एक्शन लाइक लोडिंग देयर ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम फर्मवेयर ऑपरेट इन अ सिमिलर वे टू
डिवा डिवाइस ड्राइवर ओके फर्मवेयर इ
स्टोर्ड डायरेक्टली ऑन द हार्डवेयर डिवाइस
वेयर एज ड्राइवर्स आर इंस्टॉल्ड इन द
डिवाइस ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम तो फम वेर कैन
आल्सो बाय इट सेल्फ वाइल ड्राइवर्स रिमेंस
रिलायंट ऑन द ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम तो दिस इज द
डिफरेंस बिटवीन फर्मवेयर एंड द ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम तो ऑपरेटिंग फ्रॉम वेयर क्या है कि
एक इंडिविजुअल एक छोटे-छोटे क्या है कि
इंस्ट्रक्शंस होती हैं कोई भी टास्क
परफॉर्म करने के लिए तो अगर आपको फर्मवेयर
के बारे में ज्यादा इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए तो
इसके रिलेटेड भी एक आर्टिकल्स मैंने आपके
लिए फाइंड आउट किया है तो आप इसको क्या कर
सकते हो परफॉर्म कर सकते हो इसको भी रीड
आउट कर सकते हो अपने चेक ऑफ लिस्ट में रख
सकते हो कि अगर आपको फर्द इंफो फॉर्मेशन
चाहिए कुछ और ज्यादा पढ़ना है तो फर्मवेयर
के बारे में एवरीवन गट क्लियर यहां तक
फर्मवेयर क्या होता है तो अभी दो टूल हमने
परफॉर्म किए जिसके बेसिस पर हमें कोई भी
इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं मिली ओके तो इसका मतलब यह
नहीं कि इसके अंदर कोई इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं है
ओके देखो स्टैग एनालिसिस के केस में आपको
एक चीज का ध्यान रखना है कि स्टैग
एनालिसिस एक छोटी सी प्रोसेस है जो थ्री
टू फोर स्टेप की होती है तो जब भी आप किसी
भी इमेज को ऊपर ऑडियो फाइल के ऊपर या किसी
भी वीडियो के ऊपर स्टैग एनालिसिस परफॉर्म
करना चाहते हैं तो आपको हमेशा इस कंप्लीट
प्रोसेस को फॉलो करना है अदर वाइज क्या
होता है कि आप उस प्रोसेस को को दो या तीन
स्टेप में कंप्लीट कर दोगे और आपको हो
सकता है कि वहां पर कोई इंफॉर्मेशन हाइड
की गई हो और वो आपको ना मिले क्योंकि आपने
जो स्टैक एनालिसिस का जो कंप्लीट सीक्वेंस
है वो कंप्लीट नहीं किया क्योंकि अभी देखो
अभी मैं आपको अभी आपके सामने लाइव
एग्जांपल दिखाता हूं देखो ये रहा अभी तक
हमें कोई भी इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं मिली तो देखो
फर्स्ट स्टेप हमने क्या परफॉर्म किया एजिप
टूल का यूज किया कोई वैल बल इंफॉर्मेशन
मिली सेकंड स्टेप हमने क्या परफॉर्म किया
बिनवाक को यूज किया बिनवाक से भी हमें कोई
इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं मिली जो नेक्स्ट टूल होता
आपका स्टग हाइड होता है स्टैग
हाइड स्टग हाइड अभी स्टैग हाइड हमारे
लैपटॉप से मशीन में है नहीं तो हम क्या
करेंगे सुडो एटी इंस्टॉल स्टैगइड
स्टड को क्या करेंगे इंस्टॉल
करेंगे यस अभी हम स्टक आइड को इंस्टॉल कर
रहे हैं अपने मशीन के अंदर
मतलब कंपनी इंटरव्यू में इंपैक्ट नहीं
देता बट उससे क्या होता है कि अगर आप किसी
को सीवी में डालते हो कि सर मैं मीडियम पर
आर्टिकल लिखता था मैंने यह लैब सॉल्व किए
हुए हैं मैंने यह किया हुआ है तो वह थोड़ा
सा यह पॉजिटिव इंप्रेशन शो करता है कि ओके
हां आप कुछ ना कुछ कर रहे थे आपको कुछ ना
कुछ नॉलेज है आप कहीं ना कहीं इंगेज हो
लेकिन मीडियम या आप
linked-list फायदे होंगे एक तो आप क्या
क्या कर पाओगे कि खुद से आपकी जो राइटिंग
स्किल्स हैं वो डेवलप होंगी दूसरा क्या
होता है कि आप सेल्फ एक टाइम के बाद हो
सकता है कोई कंपनी है किसी के आप नोटिस
में आओ कोई सीईओ है कोई टेक्निकल है जिनके
आप नोटिस में आओगे वो क्या करेंगे आपको
अप्रोच करेंगे और हो सकता है कि अप्रोच
करने के लिए बोला कि आप हमारे लिए भी
आर्टिकल लिखो जिससे क्या होगा कि वो आपका
एक पॉजिटिव वे है आपको एक खुद के लिए कुछ
इनकम क्रिएट करने का सोर्स मिल जाएगा
दूसरा
में क्या है कि आप आर्टिकल्स लिख रहे हो
तो बता सकते हो सर मैं कंटीन्यूअसली ये
काम कर रहा था वो काम कर रहा था जब अगर
आपसे पूछा जाता है तो उस केस में क्या कर
सकते हो आर्टिकल रेफरेंस दे सकते हो कि
मैंने इतने आर्टिकल लिखे हैं बट मोर
रिकमेंड यह होता है कि आप खुद का कोई
टूल्स खुद का कोई प्रोजेक्ट प काम करें और
कुछ ऐसा चीज जो थोड़ी सी यूनिक हो तो आपको
ज्यादा हेल्पफुल होती है ओके तो अभी यहां
पर हमने सक्सेसफुली इंस्टॉल कर लिया तो
स्टैक हाइट को भी हम कैसे यूज करते हैं
देखिए स्टैग हाइड देन उसके बाद
एक्स्टेक्स्ट इसकी हेल्प फाइल दिखाता हूं
मैं आपको हाइन हाइन हेल्प फाइल आपको शो
करता हूं यह रहा स्टैग हाइड के यह सारे
ऑप्शंस है यह देखिए द फर्स्ट आर्गुमेंट
मस्ट बी वन ऑफ द फॉलोइंग इंबेड
एक्स्टेक्स्ट
इंफो वर्जन लाइसेंस हेल्प पहला जो आपका जो
ऑप्शन होगा वह सबसे पहला आपका आर्गुमेंट
इनमें से होना चाहिए देन उसके बाद इन
ऑप्शंस को यूज करोगे ओके तो यह स्टक टूल
क्या करता है आपका कि किसी भी फाइल के
अंदर इंफॉर्मेशन हाइड करने के काम आता है
और
एक्स्टेक्स्ट करने तो स्टक हाइड उसके बाद
क्या करते हैं
एक्सट्रैक्ट एक्सट्रैक्ट
देन ये
रहा एक्स्टेक्स्ट देन उसके बाद हाइन एसएफ
यूज करेंगे हाइन एसएफ का मतलब क्या होता
है ये रहा सेलेक्ट स्टैगो फाइल स्टैगो
फाइल कौन सी जिसके ऊपर हम परफॉर्म करने
वाले हैं बुकली 99 बुकली 99 जपजी और हिट
एंटर देखिए एंटर पास
फ्रेज हमने दो टूल से इस इमेज को एनालाइज
किया और वहां
पर हमें कुछ भी इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं मिली और
जैसे हमने स्टैग हाइड का यूज किया यह क्या
है बोला एंटर पास फ्रेज पासवर्ड एंटर
कीजिए इसका मतलब इस इमेज के अंदर कुछ ना
कुछ तो इंफॉर्मेशन हाइड की गई है क्लियर
एवरीवन
यस यह आपको पासवर्ड पूछ रहा है इस फाइल को
मतलब इसके अंदर कुछ इंफॉर्मेशन है बट
हमारे पास पासवर्ड नहीं है इन दैट केस
व्हाट शुड आई डू इस केस में हम क्या
करेंगे
बताइए हमारे पास तो पास फस है नहीं अब
सिंपली हिट एंटर छोड़ा तो स्टैग हाइड कैन
नॉट अनकंप्रेस डाटा कंप्रेस डाटा इज
करप्टेड मतलब इसके अंदर डाटा है बट वी आर
नॉट एबल टू एक्सेस बिकॉज वी डोंट नो पास
फ्रेज
बताइए तो हाउ हाउ यू शुड ब्रूट फोर्स दिस
पास फ्रेज बताइए कोई टूल पता है
आपको डोंट से
हाइड्रा नो नो नो नो नो नो नो नो नो तो
इसके लिए एक बहुत ही फास्टेस्ट टूल होता
है क्रैकर्स होता है जिसके पासवर्ड क्रैक
करने काम आता है जिसका नाम है स्टैग सक
स्टैग सिक टूल होता एक अभी स्टैग स्टिक भी
हमारे में इंस्टॉल नहीं है और स्टैग स्टिक
को इंस्टॉल करने के लिए हमें एक सीक्वेंस
को फॉलो करना पड़ेगा हमें सबसे पहले गो
देन हम य यूज
करेंगे स्टैग
सीक अभ स्टैग सक को हमें इंस्टॉल करना
होगा तो वर्ल्ड फास्टेस्ट स्टैग हाइड
क्रैकर वर्ल्ड फास्टेस्ट स्टैग हाइड
क्रैकर मिलियन पासवर्ड पर सेकंड ओके
वर्ल्ड फास्टेस्ट क्रैकर अब इसको हमें
कैसे इंस्टॉल करना पड़ेगा देखिए यह बोलता
आपको इंस्टॉल करने के लिए डाउनलोड लीज
या सुडो
एटी इंस्टॉल यह रहा
सोनो डे
फाइल अभी इसको कॉपी करते हैं हम और
परफॉर्म करते
हैं शुड वी एबल टू इंस्टॉल इट लेट्स चेक
इट अनसपोर्टेड फाइल
ओके स्टग स हमें क्या करते हैं अभी अब हम
गट गिट क्लोन करके देखते हैं इसको हम
लेट्स डू इट थ्रू गिट
क्लोन ट
एंटर ओके लेस
एलस देन वे इज माय
फाइल स्टैग सक सीडी टग
सिक नाउ नाउ नाउ इज माय
फाइल सी लैंग्वेज फॉर्मेट ड एसए देन उसके
बाद अब इसको हम क्या करते हैं एक
बार परफॉर्म करके देखते हैं
नाउ डायरेक्टरी ओके
देन इन ट के वट शड आई डू बिकॉज इस टूल को
भी मैं फर्स्ट टाइम यूज कर रहा
हूं एक्सग हाइड हाउ शड आ इंस्टॉल
इट विंडोज वेरी सिंपल
नक्स पैकेज कैन य यूज द प पैकेज ओके हम एक
काम करते हैं इसको पैकेज को इंस्टॉल कर
लेते हैं अदर वाइज ड ट्राई इट फ्रॉम दिस
पैकेज डे पैकेज र
इसी को इंस्टॉल कर लेते हैं देन ओके
सक्सेसफुली ओके नाउ गो बैक ड पैकेज को हम
इंस्टॉल कर ही सकते
हैं यह
रहा मे
बी नाउ वी आर एबल टू इंस्टॉल इट मे बी
यस स्टार्टेड इंस्टॉलिंग
यस वी सक्सेसफुली इंस्टॉल दिस टूल ओके नाउ
अभी हम इसको यूज करेंगे स्टैग सख ओके
स्टैग स देन उसके बाद हमें क्या करना पड़ा
है हमें प्रोवाइड करना पड़ेगा हमारी उस
जेपीजी फाइल का नाम देन उसके बाद यहां पर
हमें प्रोवाइड करनी पड़ेगी वर्ड लिस्ट
जिसके कॉमिनेशन य क्या करेगा ट्राई करेगा
दिस इ वर्ल्ड फास्टेस्ट टूल रियली अभी
वर्ड लिस्ट कहां पर है अभी हम सीडी
डाउनलोड के अंदर है तो मेरी वर्ड लिस्ट
रहेगी आई विल चेक विज माय वर्ड लिस्ट न्यू
टैब
देन एल एस नाउ सीडी गो बैक एलएस
सीडी वर्ड लिस्ट सीडी वर्ड लिस्ट यस यस यर
मेरी क्या रोक एक्स फाइल पीडब्लूडी य रहा
दिस इज माय वर्ड लिस्ट आई
विल
सेलेक्ट वड लिस्ट और रोक डटी एक्सटी डटी
एक्सटी और सिंपली हिट
एंटर यह देखिए वर्ल्ड फास्टेस्ट ने फाइंड
आउट कर दिया फाउंड पास प्रेस एडमिन
ओरिजिनल फाइल नेम न . 9 और एक्स्टेक्स्ट
उसने एक्सट्रैक्ट भी कर दिया मतलब पासवर्ड
उसका एडमिन है उसके अंदर एक फाइल थी नो
डटी एकटी और उसने उसको एक्सट्रैक्ट करके
बकलिन 9pg आट के अंदर सेव कर दिया अगर हम
एलस करते यहां पर वे दिस फाइल एंड एंड एंड
वेर इज दिस
फाइल वेर वेर वेर ये
रही दिस इज द फाइल अगर इसको हम कैट करते
हैं
देन दिस इज फाइल ये
रही
कॉपी कंट्रोल शिफ्ट व पेस्ट हिट एंटर नाउ
होल्ड पासवर्ड होल्ड्स
पासवर्ड फ्ली डॉग एडी अब यहां पर हमें
किसका पासवर्ड मिला
होल्स सबको समझ में आ रहा है कि क्या हुआ
यहां पर
एवरीवन गट क्लियर टिल नाउ स्टैग एनालिसिस
कैसे परफॉर्म किया जा रहा है स्टैग आज ने
फाइंड आउट किया कि य मुझे इसके अंदर
इंफॉर्मेशन एक्सट्रैक्ट करने के लिए
पासवर्ड चाहिए लेकिन हमारे पास पासवर्ड
नहीं है पासवर्ड को क्रैक करने के लिए
स्टैग स टूल का यूज किया जो वर्ल्ड
फास्टेस्ट क्या है
आपका क्रैकर्स है पासवर्ड क्रैकर्स है फॉर
द हाइड जो यह इंफॉर्मेशन है जो अपने स्टस
स्टेनोग्राफी के थ्रू जो क्या किया गया है
पास फ्रेस को सेट किया गया पासवर्ड को सेट
किया गया विद द हेल्प ऑफ स्ट टूल ओके तो
इसलिए उसके लिए हमें एक वर्ड लिस्ट चाहिए
थी बेस्ट वड लिस्ट क्या थी हमारी रोड एक्
थ एवरीवन गट क्लियर टिल नाउ अब उसके बाद
हम क्या करेंगे एसएसए करेंगे वेरी गुड तो
अभी हम क्या करते हैं
एसएसए होल्ड्स देन उसके बाद ट द
रेट उसके बाद व्हाट इज अवर आईपी एड्रेस
अवर मशीन आईपी एड्रेस इज से स नाउ कंट्रोल
शिफ्ट व पेस्ट और दिस इज आवर यह पासवर्ड
रहेगा हमारा इसको भी हम क्या करेंगे अभी
कॉपी कर लेते हैं एक
बार कॉपी और अभी इसके लिए हम ट एंटर करते
य
रहा
यस हिट एंटर और कंट्रोल शिफ्ट व और हिट
एंटर नाउ परमिशन डिनाइड
पेस्ट क्लिप बोर्ड परमिशन डिनाइड मे बी वी
ओके हम एक काम करते हैं एफ एल यू एफ एफ
वाई डी ओ जी टू एट द
रेट
ना
ना ओके व्हाट इज द इशू विद ट अब इन्होंने
क्या किया होल्ड्स पासवर्ड हम इसको क्या
करते हो होल्ड करते हैं एक काम करते हैं
फिर होल्ड पासवर्ड तो हम होल्ड ट्राई करते
हैं क्योंकि यूजर नेम तो होल्ड होल्ड था
नाउ
ओके
पेस्ट नाउ वी सक्सेसफुली एंटर इन टू द
मशीन क्योंकि वो होल्स नहीं था य पर
कंफ्यूज कि क्योंकि यूजर नेम क्या था
होल्ड था जो हमने एफटीपी के थ्रू फाइंड
आउट किया था
तो उस केस में आपके पास इंफॉर्मेशन या
वर्डलिस्ट अच्छी होनी चाहिए हिट एल ट्राली
है उस केस में भी आपको क्रैकर का यूज करना
है लेकिन वह वर्डलिस्ट आपको खुद से क्रिएट
करनी होगी अगर आपको आईडिया है कि पासवर्ड
पॉलिसी के हिसाब से इन्होने नंबर्स और
पैटर्न का कॉमिनेशन यूज किया है तो इन दैट
केस आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा एक मैनुअल वर्ड
लिस्ट क्रिएट करनी होगी विद द हेल्प ऑफ
कंच टूल
देन आपको वह वर्ड लिस्ट यहां पर यूज करनी
होगी देन अभी हम यहां पर क्या करते हैं
चेक करते हैं एलस करते हैं तो नाउ नड से
और यूर डटी एकटी यूजर डटी एक्सटी हम कैट
करते हैं अपना यूजर डटी एक्टी हिट एंटर यह
रहा दिस इज आवर
फर्स्ट यूजर डटी एक्सटी एंड व्हाट इज दिस
यूर डटी एक्सटी में हमें क्या मिला आ
फ्लैग
मे बी यस दिस इज आवर
फ्लैग यह
रहा कॉपी एंड सबमिट दिस फ्लैग अभी हम इसको
क्या करते हैं यहां पर सबमिट कर देते हैं
पेस्ट एंड
सबमिट नाउ सक्सेसफुली हमने यूजर फ्लैग को
फाइंड आउट कर लिया नाउ आवर टास्क इज टू
फाइंड आउट द रूट फ्लैग उसके लिए हमें क्या
करना पड़ेगा लिनक्स प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन
करना पड़ेगा मतलब अभी हमें अन प्रिविलेज
यूजर अकाउंट है अगर मैं प्रिविलेज को चेक
करूंगा तो क्या मैं एक काम कर सकता हूं कि
सीडी रूट एक्सेस कर सकता हूं परमिशन
डिनाइड क्या मैं कैट करके य देख स कैट
ईटीसी पास ड्डी ओके यह फाइल मैं देख सकता
हूं देखो जैक एफटीपी होल्ड यह सारे के
सारे एम ये सारे सारे इसके अंदर ओके इसको
मैं देख सकता हूं क्लियर क्या मैं एक काम
कर सकता कैट स्ल
टीसी स्लश
शैडो शैडो फाइल को देख सकता हूं परमिशन
डिनाइड अभी मैं मुझे आप लोगों से एक चीज
जाननी है क्या नेक्स्ट क्लास में आफ्टर
एक्सप्लोइटेशन हम पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज
में लोकल एन्यूमरेशन परफॉर्म करते हैं
क्या आप लोग इंटरेस्टेड हो कि हम नक् के
ऊपर लोकल नमरे कैसे परफॉर्म करते हैं लोकल
एमेशन में जैसे कि नेटवर्क इंफॉर्मेशन
आपकी सिस्टम इंफॉर्मेशन या आपके यूजर्स की
इंफॉर्मेशन यह सारी हम कैसे परफॉर्म करते
हैं क्या यह चीज मैं आपको एक्सप्लेन करूं
या खुद से कर लोगे क्योंकि य पोस्ट एक्सशन
के बाद एक स्टेज होती है लोकल एमरे क्या
वह आपको मैं सिखाऊं या नहीं सिखाऊ या आप
लोगों से पूछ रहा हूं बताइए मुझे तो अभी
हमारे पास कोई भी परमिशन नहीं है यहां पर
परफॉर्म करने के लिए तो अभी हम कैसे चेक
करें अगर मैं प प्रेजेंट वर्किंग
डायरेक्टर मेरी क्या है होल्ट ओके तो अभी
मैं इससे ज्यादा कुछ नहीं कर स मैं अपने
प्रिविलेजेस को देखता हूं सुडो हाइन एल
दीज आर माय प्रिविलेजेस नो पासवर्ड बिन
ननो मैं एज ए रूट यूजर्स एज सूडो यूजर्स
विदाउट पासवर्ड जो मेरे ननो है किसके अंदर
किसके अंदर ननो किसके अंदर हमारे बिन
डायरेक्टरी के अंदर बिन क्या है बाइनरी
डायरेक्टरी तो मेरी ननो क्या एक बाइनरी
फाइल है एक एग्जीक्यूटेबल फाइल्स है है
जिसके ऊपर हमें रूट एक्सेस है तो मुझे
क्या करना है इसको एक्सप्लोइट करना है तो
मैं कैसे कर सकता हूं
बताइए तो आज नहीं सिखाऊंगा तो नेक्स्ट
क्लास में सिखाऊंगा फिर मैं तो नेक्स्ट
क्लास से हो सकता है कि हमारे जो लैब्स
हैं एक से तीन दिन ले ले सॉल्व होने में
क्योंकि उनमें टॉपिक बढ़ जाएंगे और टॉपिक
के साथ-साथ बेसिक कांसेप्ट बढ़ जाएंगे जो
एक्सप्लेन करने बहुत ज्यादा जरूरी है जैसे
कई बार आपका बब सूट आ जाएगा बब सूट को
एक्सप्लेन करना पड़ जाएगा देन उसके बाद जो
अभी मैंने बात की आपको लोकल एन्यूमरेशन की
बात की उसमें एक टॉपिक है जैसे मैं आपको
बताऊंगा
कि रिवर्स सेल कैसे लेते हैं या
एक्सप्लोइट कैसे फाइंड आउट करते हैं तो
इनके लिए एक अपना टॉपिक है तो पूरी क्लास
लग जाए डेडिकेटेड क्लास प उसके लिए आपको
मेरे से कंप्लेन नहीं करना कि सर सीटीएफ
को कंप्लीट सॉल्व नहीं कर रहे आप सीटीएफ
को कंप्लीट सॉल्व करेंगे बट इट दे विल टेक
टाइम फ्रॉम वन टू थ्री क्लास मे बी एक
क्लास या दो क्लास हो सकती है ओके तो उसके
लिए शायद आपको रेडी होना होगा मिस आउट
नहीं करना होगा उसके लिए आप लोग रेडी
हो तो य पर हमें क्या करना अभी इसके
लिए क्या चेक करना है एक्सट चेक करना तो
हम क्या करेंगे जीटीएफ विन पर चलते हैं
हमें पता है नक्स लेे जीटी एफ बिनस ओके
जीटी
बिन हिट एंटर नाउ क्लिक और हमें एज सूडो
प्रज कौन स हमें अभी हम चेक करते हैं
यह रहा यहां पर हम चेक करते हैं
ननो यह रहा ननो हमें मिल गया क्लिक ऑन द
ननो अभी हमें क्या सुडो प्रिविलेज है देखो
इफ द बाइनरी इ अलाउड टू रन एज सुपर यूजर
बाय सुडो इट डज नॉट ड्रॉप द एलिवेटेड
प्रिविलेजेस एंड मे बी यूज टू एक्सेस द
फाइल सिस्टम एस्केलेट और मेंटेन प्रिविलेज
एक्सेस ओके तो हमें सबसे पहले क्या करना
है हमें परफॉर्म करना है सुडो ननो सो सबसे
पहले हम कॉपी करेंगे और परफॉर्म करेंगे
सुडो और ननो य टेंटर सुडो ननो परफॉर्म
किया ओके अभी यहां पर यह बोल रहा आपको
समझना देखो य क्या बोल रहा है कंट्रोल आर
और कंट्रोल एक्स कंट्रोल आर और कंट्रोल
एक्स अभी मैं क्या करता हूं यहां पर जैसे
कंट्रोल
आर कंट्रोल आर कंट्रोल ओके कंट्रोल एक्स
करेंगे क कंट्रोल एक्स होता है एग्जीक्यूट
कमांड अग मैं इसको कंट्रोल फलेक्स करता
हूं तो क्या होगा ओके कमांड एग्जीक्यूट तो
मैं फिर से दिखा देता हूं एक काम कर देता
हूं मैं इसको एक बार क्लोज करता हूं फिर
से एक बार मैं क्या करता हूं कैंसिल
कंट्रोल सी ये रहा अभी मैं फिर से कंट्रोल
x डायरेक्ट अभी इसने बोला था कि सुडो ननो
करना है तो सुडो ननो देन आपको पहले सबसे
पहले प्रेस करना है कंट्रोल r जैसे आपने
कंट्रोल आर किया यहां पर आगा फाइल टू
इंसर्ट फ्रॉम फाइल टू इंसर्ट फ्रॉम यहां
पर और भी ऑप्शंस है गेट हेल्प कैंसल
कंट्रोल एक्स एग्जीक्यूट कमांड इसके अंदर
एक ऑप्शन है तो कंट्रोल एक्स एग्जीक्यूट
कमांड यहां पर हम क्या करेंगे अपनी जो
कमांड थी ये रही रिसेट एस एच कौन सा
नॉर्मल सेल कंट्रोल सी कॉपी एंड पेस्ट अब
यहां पर हम क्या कर देंगे पेस्ट कर देंगे
पेस्ट यहां पर कर दिया देन उसके बाद क्या
करना है हमें
ओके देन उसके बाद हमें क्या करना है ओके
करना है शायद ओके
देन उसके बाद कंट्रोल
एक्स मे बी मे बी टो
विटो यह रहा अभी ट एंटर करर तो हमें क्या
मिल गया देखो सेल मिल गया य रहा हमें सेल
मिल गया य देखो अगर मैं य पर क्या करता
हूं पीडब्लूडी
प्रेजेंट वर्ड की डायरेक्टरी होम होल्ड
एंड एलस करता हूं यह रहा नैनो और सेव नैनो
और सेव और मैं आगे सीडी करता हूं सिंपली
अग नो सेव को मैं पढ़ के देखता हूं
कैट नड
सेव एन ए एओड सेव इसको मैं पढ़ता हूं यह
देखो एक
मिनट वेट वेट वेट कैट
नो डॉट सेव ट एंटर यह देखिए इसके अंदर कुछ
नहीं
है हैंग अप बिन डायरेक्ट बन इ डायरेक्टरी
अभी मैं क्या करता हूं प्रेजेंट वर्क
डायरेक्टरी होम होल्ड सीडी रूट करते हैं
हम सीडी रूट ट एंटर एलस परफॉर्म करते हैं
रट एक्स सबको समझ में आ गया अभी कैट करते
रट डटी एक्सटी रट डॉटी एक्सटी
हिट एंटर हम सक्सेसफुली हमने क्या किया
अपना प्रिविलेज एलेशन परफॉर्म किया और
यहां पर रूट फ्लैग को भी फाइंड आउट कर
लिया यह रहा दिस इज आवर रूट फ्लैग कॉपी
एंड पेस्ट यह रहा नाउ अगेन एको थर्ड
सीटीएफ था हमने सक्सेसफुली परफॉर्म कर
लिया यह रहा दिस इज आवर थर्ड
सीटीएफ सबको समझ में आ गया
एवरीवन कि कैसे परफॉर्म किया
पहले हमने क्या किया था इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग किया एनम मेशन किया पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग किया पोर्ट स्कैनिंग के बाद हमने
क्या किया एफटीपी को मिस कन्फर एटी प के
थ्रू एक फाइल हमें मिली फाइल को हमने रीड
आउट किया उससे हमें पता चला कि जो जैक नाम
का एक यूजर नेम है उसका एक पासवर्ड उसका
पासवर्ड वीक है तो उसको हमें क्या करना है
ब्रूट फोर्स करना है देन उसके बेस पर हमें
क्रेड मिल जाएंगे और हमें एसएसएस के थ्रू
एक्सेस लेना है मशीन के अंदर बाकी क्या
चीज थी हमने पोर्ट एटी चेक किया पोर्ट टी
के अंदर हमें इमेज और टेक्स्ट मिला
टेक्स्ट के अंदर में कुछ भी यूजफुल
इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं मिली सोर्स कोड रिव्यू
किया उसके अंदर भी कोई भी इंफॉर्मेशन यूज
इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं मिली robot.txt फाइल को
चेक किया नो यूजफुल इंफॉर्मेशन अगर आप
इसके ऊपर डर बस्टर परफॉर्म करते तो देन
आल्सो आपको कोई भी यूजफुल इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं
मिलती इन दैट केस आपके पास अदर ऑप्शन जो
बचा था वो था आपके पास स्टैगो ग्राफी
स्टैग एनालिसिस आपने स्टैग एनालिसिस किया
इमेज का परफॉर्म किया तो स्टैग एनालिसिस
की प्रोसेस होती है थ्री टू फोर स्टेप
प्रोसेस होती है जो आपको हमेशा याद रखनी
है उसको फॉलो करना है तो सबसे पहले आपने
एजिप डाटा को एनालाइज किया एग्जिट डाटा
में आपको कुछ भी यूजफुल इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं
मिली देन उसके बाद आपने बिन वक्त टूल का
यूज किया उस टूल की हेल्प से आपने
इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश की
जिसका नाम वहां पर भी आपको कोई भी
इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं मिली और बिनवाक क्या एक
का फर्मवेयर एनालिसिस टूल है देन थर्ड
स्टेप हमने परफॉर्म किया स्टैग एनालिसिस
के अंदर स्टैग हाइ टूल का यूज किया स्टैग
हाई टूल की हेल्प से आपने जब भी उसको
एनालाइज करने की कोशिश की तो उसने आपसे एक
पास फ्रेज मांगी एक पासवर्ड मांगा जो आपके
पास नहीं था तो उससे आपको कंफर्म हो गया
इस इमेज के अंदर कुछ ना कुछ छुपा हुआ कुछ
ना कुछ कोई फाइल है तो देन आपने क्या किया
एक वर्ल्ड फास्टेस्ट क्रैकर है जिसका नाम
स्टैग सिक उसका यूज किया उसको यूज करके
आपने क्या किया उस पासवर्ड को क्रैक किया
पासवर्ड को क्रैक करके उसके अंदर एक फाइल
थी थी उस फाइल को फाइंड आउट किया उस फाइल
को रीड किया उस फाइल में आपको होल्ट जो
यूजर नेम था उसका पासवर्ड मिला उस पासवर्ड
को यूज करते हुए आपने एसएसएस लॉग इन किया
एसएसएस लॉग इन करने के बाद आपको
अनप्रिविलेज्ड यूजर अकाउंट में एक्सेस मिल
गया वहां पर आपको अपना पहला फ्लैग मिल गया
लेकिन वहां पर आपके पास कोई भी
प्रिविलेजेस नहीं है उस केस में आपको क्या
करना है प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन करना है अब
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन करने के लिए आपके पास
क्या है कि यह पता होना चाहिए कि जो करंट
यूजर है उसके पास क्या-क्या प्रिविलेज हैं
तो मेरे पास क्या प्रिविलेज था कि मैं जो
नैनो बाइनरी फाइल थी उसको एज ए सुपर यूजर
रन कर सकता हूं विदाउट एनी पासवर्ड वहां
पर मेरे को परमिशन थी सुडो हान एल की
हेल्प से पता चल गया तो हमने जीटीएफ विन
की हेल्प से नो का एक्सप्लोइट फाइंड आउट
किया उस एक्सप्लोइट को यूज किया विद दी
हेल्प ऑफ दैट एक्सप्लोइट वी आर एबल टू
फाइंड रूट प्रिविलेजेस और हमें क्या करना
मशीन का रूट एक्सेस मिल गया जब हमें मशीन
का रूट एक्सेस मिल जाता है तो वी आर द
एडमिन यूजर वी आर द सुपर यूजर और हम इस
केस में मशीन के साथ कुछ भी कर सकते हैं
तो हमें वहां पर सेकंड फ्लैग मिल गया दिस
इज द टोटल समरी ऑफ दिस लैब तो एवरीवन गट
क्लियर टिल नाउ प्लीज एक्सप्लेन या प्लीज
टेल मी नाउ
सर मेरे पास ट्राई हैमी का फ्री वर्जन है
कैसे करोगे प्लीज नेक्स्ट मशीन सोल सोल
उसे विदाउट विदाउट ओपन वीपीएन देखो विदाउट
ओपन वीपीएन तो मैं आपको क्या बता रहा हूं
कि आपको जो वन ववर मिलता है वह सफिशिएंट
नहीं है और वह मशीन इतनी स्लो होती है
इतनी स्लो होती है यू आर नॉट एबल टू सॉल्व
द मशीन बिकॉज बहुत स्लो
उसके लिए आपको अपनी मशीन में उसको ओपन वपन
के थ्रू कनेक्शन बनाना ही
पड़ेगा देखिए ब बग बाउंट की क्लास नहीं है
यह पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग की क्लास है और
इसके लिए मैं अभी डेडिकेटेड वीडियो तो
नहीं बना सकता बट आप सीरीज में शायद मुझे
जहां तक पता है कि नितेश सर ने हर चीज को
स्टेप बाय स्टेप सॉल्व किया व हर चीज को
स्टेप बाय स्टेप बताया कैसे लैब सेटअप की
जा
और बग बाउंट के केस में भी अलग से कोई लब
सेटअप तो है नहीं है काली नेक्स का यूज
करना है उसके बाद आपको बग क्राउड जैसे
प्लेटफॉर्म से टारगेट चूज करने हैं देन
उसके बाद टूल्स को परफॉर्म करना है टूल्स
को डाउनलोड करने के लिए आपको फिर वह खुद
से ही ट्राई करना
होगा हां बोलो एनोनिमस आपका क्या सवाल
है ओपन वीपीएन फाइल तो फ्री आप यूज कर
सकते
हो मुझे तो कभी टाइम लिमिटेशन नहीं
मिला यह जो फर्स्ट एटीएफ लैब में ओपन
वीपीएन फाइल को मैंने आपको मान सिंह शर्मा
बताया था कैसे मैंने यूज किया
काली लिनस का लैब सेटअप में क्या प्रॉब्लम
है
बताओ जीजी यार व लैब्स अवेलेबल है अभी
लेटेस्ट मशीन भी वही है एज इट इज स्टेप
सारे सेम होते हैं आप चाहे ओल्ड मशीन को
सेट अप करो या ओल्ड वीडियो को देख के सेट
अप करो और नए वर्जन को सेट अप करो तो
स्टेप्स ल स्टेप्स आर सेम
तो अभी मैं इस पर लाइव
तो इन क्लास के बीच में डिस्टर्ब तो नहीं
कर सकता
क्योंकि प्रॉब्लम इज दैट कि बाकी लोग
स्टूडेंट नहीं आएंगे मेरे क्लास में तो यह
मेरे पास रेट लिमिट है इस चीज
की तो आपको अपने काले को हमेशा अपग्रेड
करना है आप अपने काले को सुडो सबसे पहला
काम सुडो एपीडी अपडेट करो ठीक है और अगर
आपका इंटरनेट बंद हो रहा है तो काली की
वजह से इंटरनेट बंद नहीं हो रहा होगा आपके
मशीन की प्रॉब्लम है
वो दिस इ द जीरो टू इंटरमीडिएट कोर्स इससे
बेटर कोर्स क्या मिलेगा ने और नेक्स्ट
कोर्स जो मैं पढ़ाता हूं वह मेरा एंड्राइड
हैकिंग कोर्स होता है वह ब्लैक हैट टाइप
का रहता है क्योंकि एंड्राइड पन टेस्टिंग
कोर्स जिसका नाम है और उसका जो सिलेबस है
व ब्लैक हेट लेवल का जहां पर आपको रिवर्स
इंजरिंग
और बहुत सारी चीजें आपको सिखाई जाती हैं
जहां पर एक एप्लीकेशंस को आप रिवर्स इंजन
कर सकते हो उसके अंदर फेर कोड भी खुद से
लिख सकते हो स्माली जैसी लैंग्वेज का यूज
कर सकते हो तो एक एक वो कोर्स है उसके बाद
ये जीरो टू इंटरमीडिएट कोर्स है देन इसके
बाद एक एडवांस कोर्स होगा वो भी मैं आपको
पढ़ाऊंगा इसके बाद क्योंकि यह तो ब उसका
बच्चा है एडवांस कोर्स में तो बहुत कुछ
होता है कि आप मैं आपको हिंट दे देता हूं
जैसे कि कमांड एंड कंट्रोल सर्वर आ जाते
हैं एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी पेन टेस्टिंग आ
जाती है आपके सोशल इंजीनियरिंग एडवांस
अटैक्स आ जाते हैं जैसे कि क्लाइंट साइड
अटैक जिनको हम बोलते हैं कि आप सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग कैसे परफॉर्म कर सकते हो
प्रैक्टिकली देन उसके बाद आपकी जो हम
बोलेंगे पावर सेल पावर सेल एज ए पेन
टेस्टस हमें कैसे पता होना चाहिए
जावास्क्रिप्ट एज ए पन टेस्टर्स हमें पता
होनी चाहिए देन बहुत सारी चीज है
आपके आप बोलोगे टर्स क्यूबस हाउ टू स्टे
एनोनिमस वाले टॉपिक्स भीसी के पार्ट होते
हैं एंड वास पट टेस्टिंग और देन ब दे आर
लॉट ऑफ टॉपिक्स आपने अगर प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन यह तो क्या है कि जस्ट एक डेमो
है एक प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन का कंप्लीट वह
होता है कि एक अगर बूट कैंप मान के चलोगे
आप लोग मेरे को बोलोगे कि सर हम वी आर
रेडी टू टेक द बूट कैंप ऑफ प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन का भी मैं
पूरा बूट कैंप आपको डिलीवर कर सकता हूं
बोथ 0 टू एक एडवांस लेवल का बूट कैंप ऑन द
मेरा पढ़ाने का तरीका कैसा है कि मैं कैसे
हमेशा चाहे कोर्स कोई भी स्टार्ट करूं
लेकिन मैं एक लेवल से स्टार्ट करता हूं कि
सो दैट कि आपको क्लियर हो जाए उसके बाद
लेटरल मूवमेंट्स होते हैं तो इतने सारे
टॉपिक्स हैं आपके एडवांस जैसे क्लाउड पन
टेस्टिंग आ जाती है और एंड्राइड पन
टेस्टिंग भी आप एडवांस में ही मान सकते हो
अगर आप सीखना चाहो तो दे आर लॉट ऑफ टॉपिक
दैट यू कैन लर्न इन एडवांस पन टेस्टिंग
एंड द प्रोफेशनल पन टेस्टिंग वेब में भी
क्या है किय दज आर द बेसिक टॉपिक्स एंड
वेब एप्लीकेशन में दे आर लॉट ऑफ एडवांस
टॉपिक्स आर अवेलेबल ल् तो यह भी आपके क्या
है
कि एक एडवांस कोर्स के पार्ट है तो अगर आप
डेडिकेट अगर कोर्स बोलोगे लंच करने के लिए
अगर मेरे को बोले सर आप पढ़ाओ और मेरे को
या कोई भी पढ़ाए और डायरेक्टली आपको ओनली
एडवांस पेनिट्रेशन कौन सी ऑफेंसिव ऑफेंस
कौन सी रेड टीमिंग सबको पता है रेड टीमिंग
क्या होता
है सभी को पता है रेड
टीमिंग अभी रेड टीमिंग लेवल की आपको पेन
टेस्टिंग सीखनी है ऑफेंसिव प टेस्टिंग
सीखनी है उसके लिए एडवांस भी है ये तो बस
आपके फंडामेंटल्स प्लस में एक लेवल है वो
एडवांस है अगर मैं ऑफेंसिव टेस्टिंग
सिखाने लग जाऊं तो मान के चलो कि अगर मैं
कोर्स अगर उसको मैं खुद से अकेला डिलीवर
करता हूं फोर टू फाइव मंथ में इतना एडवांस
टॉपिक्स अवेलेबल हैं दो आपको पता भी नहीं
होंगे जैसे कि एक्सप्लोइट डेवलपमेंट बफर
ओवरफ्लो एक्सप्लोइट डेवलपमेंट उसको कैसे
कर सकते रिवर्स इंजरिंग इज आल्सो ए पार्ट
ऑफ दिस दिस एडवांस पन टेस्टिंग आपको पता
होना चाहिए रिवर्स इंजरिंग कैसे याद करनी
पड़ पड़ सकती है कई बार आपको अपने उसके
लिए आपको एक्सप्लोर डेवलप करना भी आना
चाहिए सार जज आर द पार्ट्स ऑफ द एडवांस
पेन
टेस्टिंग एडवांस सीखना है तो उसके लिए एक
डेडिकेटेड फीस होगी डेडिकेटेड
ड्यूरेशन होगी और स्टूडेंट्स भी चाहिए अभी
मैं दो स्टूडेंट्स के लिए तो नहीं कर सकता
ना किसी एडवांस पन टेस्टिंग कोर्स को
स्टार्ट करने के लिए एडवांस पन टेस्टिंग
कोर्स स्टार्ट करने के लिए एटलीस्ट 100
स्टूडेंट तो मुझे चाहिए क्योंकि उसमें
मेरा बहुत एफर्ट लगने वाला है एडवांस पेन
टेस्टिंग कोस में बहुत ज्यादा एफर्ट यू
नेवर थिंक अबाउट इट कि हाउ मच एफर्ट बिकॉज
यह मेरा फ्री वाला कोर्स इसमें देखिए आपकी
एक क्लास डिलीवर करने के लिए ववन आपका
सीटीएफ ही क्यों ना हो सीटीएफ को एक लेवल
तक डिलीवर करने के लिए उसका एक लेवल सेटअप
करने के लिए आई टेक टू डेज मैं अपना
पर्सनल टाइम जो भी मैं मुझे अपने फैमिली
के साथ स्पेंड करना चाहिए वो सारा पर्सनल
टाइम आप लोगों के लिए वहां पर स्पेंड करता
हूं पीपीटी रेडी करता हूं कहां पर क्या
बोलना है और पूरा मतलब कि रेडी करता हूं
पूरी क्लास को उसके बाद एक खुद से एक बार
अकेला बैठ के इसी इतनी डेढ़ घंटे की
ड्यूरेशन में खुद से ट्राई करता हूं कि
हां पर मुझे क्या बोलना आपका क्या सवाल हो
सकता है उस सवाल को सोचता हूं उसका आंसर
क्या हो सकता है आपके लिए बेस्ट रिसोर्सेस
क्या होगा बेस्ट वे क्या होगा आपको समझ
में सारी चीज सोचने के बाद दो दिन बाद
आपके पास एक क्लास डिलीवर होती है दिस इज
माय एफर्ट और मुझे एफर्ट में क्या मिलता
है देर ओनली 20 स्टूडेंट्स 20 30
स्टूडेंट्स दिस इज माय
एफर्ट दिस सेमलेस फ ठीक है कोई भी कोई
youtube2
की दिस टाइप्स ऑफ हैकिंग यू आर लर्निंग इन
दय एंड दिस इनके जो व्यूज है इनके जो
स्टूडेंट्स दे सर यू आर सो यजीएस या सर यू
आर इंटरेस्टिंग सर यह सारी
चीजें इनकी बात करते हैं फिर आप आप ऐसी
पेंटेस्टिंग सीखना चाहते हो अब वे कहां
बैठे हैं फिर
बस बस वो इतना सीख लेते हैं एक टाइम के
बाद की दे आर स्किप कीडी दे आर नॉट सेल्फ
इंटरेस्टेड कुछ सीटीएफ सॉल्व करना सीख
लेंगे या उसके बाद क्या करेंगे दे
डायरेक्टली ट्राई ऑन द ब्लैक वेज ब्लैक
पेंटेस्टिंग डायरेक्ट ट्राई करते हैं कि
किसी को फ्रॉड करना वो करना क्या मिल
जाएगा यार
नथिंग उसके बाद उनका अगला मोटो क्या होता
है उसके बेस कोर्स सेल करते हैं कि बोला
नहीं
और वह चीज आपसे 50 20 30 लाख र तक ले
लेंगे देन आपको इस लेवल के फिर भी मैं मान
सकता हूं कि शायद तब मिल
जाए वेरी जीजी बब सूट को कनेक्ट करना एड
मोबाइल फोन से बहुत इजी
है एक स्टूडेंट से काम नहीं चलता ना मैं
अभी देखना एक जल्दी में हम अनाउंसमेंट
करेंगे तो अगर कोई हम एक जस्ट एक वर्कशॉप
देखते हैं 14 टू 15 डेज का एक लेवल होगा
जिसका मे बी आई एम गिविंग यू मे बी सम
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग वर्कशॉप आई विल ट्राई जो
थ्योरी प्लस प्रैक्टिकल्स होगा एक
सिनेरियो बेसिस होगा उसमें देखना कितने
स्टूडेंट्स आएंगे मिनिमम अमाउंट में
बिल्कुल वेरी वेरी आपके एक रिचार्ज लेवल
अब मैं बोलूं तो अगर आपको विचार्ज लेवल का
अमाउंट भी रख दूं जब भी आप मैं बोलता हूं
कि 100 स्टूडेंट क्रॉस नहीं करेंगे आप ऐसे
स्टूडेंट्स हो
अभी मैं कुछ भी एक्सपोज नहीं कर सकता
बिकॉज आई एम प्रिपेयरिंग द सिलेबस और आई
एम प्रिपेयरिंग द लोगो आल्सो एंड
प्रिपेयरिंग द देर लॉट ऑफ थिंग्स आई एम
प्रिपेयरिंग फॉर यू गाइस तो बस आई रिकमेंड
वन थिंग और आई विल से वन थिंग कि प्लीज से
योर मनी फॉर माय कोर्सेस एंड माय डेफ
एक्सटीम कोर्सेस एंड वंस यू गोट
अपॉर्चुनिटी
डायरेक्टली इन्वेस्ट देम ओके यू नेवर
डिसपे फ्रॉम माय टीम मेरी टीम का चाहे कोई
भी कोर्स हो साइबर क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेशन
कोर्स हो चाहे वो मेरा हम मैं उस कोर्स को
पढ़ाता हूं चाहे मेरा एड पेन टेस्टिंग
कोर्स हो चाहे वो डिजिटल फॉस कोर्स हो
चाहे हमारे जो मैम पढ़ाती इंग्लिश वर्जन
उनका कोर्स हो या नितेश सर तो आप पहले से
जानते हो हर एक कोर्स एक वैल बल
इंफॉर्मेशन के साथ एक वैल बल कंटेंट के
साथ होता है उसका एक लेवल होता है और
हम आई कांट से एनीथिंग ब ब्लैक वाइपर
बिकॉज टिल नाउ आई डोंट डिसाइड एनीथिंग
प्राइस और कंप्लीट कोर्स बिकॉज आई एम
डिजाइनिंग द कोर्स नाउ बिकॉज मुझे बहुत
सारे आपके सिनेरियो सोचने होंगे क्योंकि
स्टूडेंट्स कुछ लो भी होंगे कुछ हाई
प्रोफाइल्स भी होंगे तो ह स्टूडेंट को
सोचना पड़ेगा और एक सिलेबस रेडी करने में
टाइम चाहिए होता है तो अभी वह टाइम मुझे
लग रहा है सिलेबस मेरे सिलेबस हर सिलेबस
से अलग होते हैं थोड़े डिजाइन के हुए
थोड़ी हटके होते हैं मैच कर सकते हैं बट
थोड़े से कांसेप्ट हटके हो सकते
हैं ओके तो आई होप कि सबको आज की
क्लास मजेदार रही होगी सबको अच्छे से समझ
आ गई होगी और नेक्स्ट जो सीटी परफॉर्म
करेंगे वो काफी इंटरेस्टिंग हां आप लोगों
के लिए चलो अगर को टास्क परफॉर्म करना है
तो मेरे पास एक आर्टिकल्स है यू कैन आल्सो
यूज दिस
आर्टिकल्स डेड फेस सीटीएफ स्टेनोग्राफी
इसके अंदर कुछ इमेजेस अवेलेबल है आप टेगो
ग्राफी की प्रैक्टिस कर सकते हो यहां पर
यह यहां पर प्रैक्टिस कर सकते हो लो यह
रहा इसके अंदर जाइए दे आर फोर इमेजेस आर
अवेलेबल इस मीडियम आर्टिकल के अंदर उनको
जो मैंने सिखाया है ना उसकी हेल्प से
एक्चुअली उनको उन्होंने आंसर भी दिया हुआ
है बताया भी हुआ है बट डोंट फॉलो द वक
थ्रो सिंपली यूज द इमेजेस और इमेजेस को
हमेशा वर्चुअल एनवायरमेंट में रन करना
डायरेक्टली मशीन पर मत रन करना कई बार
क्या होता है और भी चीज हो जाती है तो आप
इससे प्रैक्टिस कर सकते हो जो जितने लोग
सॉल्व करते हैं देखते
हैं इमेज ट्रोजन के साथ हैकिंग कैसे करते
हैं तो इमेज ट्रोजन के के साथ हैकिंग करने
के लिए पहले बात तो आपका पूरा एनवायरमेंट
अगर आपका इमेज ट्रोजन है अगर आप खुद से
क्रिएट कर रहे हो तब भी आपको अपना पूरा
एनवायरमेंट सैंड बॉक्स एनवायरमेंट रखना
पड़ेगा मतलब आपके फिजिकल कंप्यूटर को कोई
इफेक्ट ना हो उसके बाद आपको अभी डिपेंड
करता है कि किस टाइप से आप ट्रोजन क्रिएट
करना चाह रहे हो किसम क्रिएट करना चाह रहे
हो डिपेंड्स ऑन द आपके टारगेट मशीन पर
डिपेंड करता है आप ब्लाइंड हर मशीन के लिए
तो नहीं बना सकते या तो आपको ऐसी चीज
सोचनी होगी ये भी आपकी इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
पर डिपेंड करता है कि ट्रोजन कैसे डिजाइन
कर बट यह बात ही ना करो तो सही है क्योंकि
आपका मुझे मेंटालिटी सही नहीं सर हाउ टू
हैकिंग विद एन इमेज ट्रोजन अगर आपका सवाल
ही ऐसा है तो मुझे लगता है कि आपकी
मेंटालिटी यहां पर सही नहीं है तो आई एम
सॉरी फॉर गाइस आपको मैं अभी इससे ज्यादा
मैं आपको इसको आंसर नहीं
करूंगा सो व्हाट इज द बेस्ट मेथड टू
इंस्टॉल नक् नक् इंस्टॉल करने का बेस्ट
मेथड है कि डायरेक्टली आपको काने डाउनलोड
कीजिए डाउनलोड करने के बाद फॉलो द स्टेप
कहीं पर भी आप सर्च करोगे ना कि हाउ टू
इंस्टॉल काली नेक्स लेटेस्ट वर्जन आपको
कोई भी ट्यूटोरियल भी मिल जाएगा यार आपको
इससे चिंता करने की जरूरत ही नहीं है
सर तो जीरो नॉलेज है तो मैं आपको बता रहा
हूं यार आर आर राज होनन आई एम आम एबल टू
आई एम नॉट एबल टू प्रोनाउंस योर नाम नेम
तो डे वन टू नाउ डे 20 तक हर एक चीज
बिल्कुल जीरो जीरो फ्रॉम जीरो है य और अगर
तुम्हें यह नहीं पता कि कंप्यूटर क्या
होता है और आपको यह नहीं पता कि सीपीयू
क्या होता है मॉनिटर क्या होता है कीबोर्ड
क्या होता है माउस क्या होता है और उसको
कैसे ऑन ऑफ और उसके अंदर क्याक चीजें होती
है उनका फंडामेंटल आपका क्लियर नहीं है तो
देन लीव द क्लास और फर्स्ट ऑफ ल जॉइन एनी
कंप्यूटर क्लासेस फॉर सिक्स मंथ एंड
क्लियर योर फंडामेंटल्स देन जॉइन दिस
फ्रीली अवेलेबल से आप कर सकते हो
आज की क्लास इतनी ही है
ओके
तो आज की क्लास को एंड करते हैं तो थैंक
यू गाय गाय बाय बाय सॉरी आई एम सॉरी फॉर
दैट ओके बाय बाय आपका अगर एक लाख तक का
बजट है तो आप तो कोई भी गेमिंग लैपटॉप
ट्राई कीजिए साइबर सिक्योरिटी के लिए
और मैकबुक आर नॉट गुड फॉर द साइबर
सिक्योरिटीज ओके बाय बाय थैंक यू एंड सी
यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन और नेक्स्ट सेक्शन
जल्दी मिलेंगे नेक्स्ट सेक्शन में भी और
वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग सेशन होगा और भी नए
टॉपिक के साथ नई लैब के साथ और नए
एक्सपीरियंस हम लेंगे नए टूल्स के साथ हम
परफॉर्म करेंगे ओके तो बाय बाय टेक केयर
सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन एंड